[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
Lloyd of attractiveness. It's just noise
coming out your mouth, son Caden Cuddy.
The beginning was really interesting.
I like it.
But then that whole whiny part in the
middle. I wasn't feeling that shit. Yo,
you just got to high Joe. Is that
what it was? We think so. Yeah.
He can't handle his weight. Do you think
that because you're too high, maybe.
Maybe John Fun. Are you too high?
I am not high at all. What? I know.
Oh, I see what, you know
what Scott corporate gigs.
I'm, no, I'm not. I'm literally not. How's
that possible? I'm, I think I'm immune.
I think, uh, I mean to marijuana.
I think so. I've never like,
you know, I was in college
and stuff like that. I would,
I would waste it and I would see people
get high off of like a hit or two and I
go, I just wasted an entire bag and I'm
not, I don't think I breathe in properly.
Or You were just telling us
about eating it. Yeah. I've only,
I'm a big fan cause I'm
not fan of coughing and I'm
not fan of that act cause I
think I'm going to die every time.
So if I do on just I eat it,
which is cool cause I literally,
and anytime
I do,
I get lost.
So lost in a music before
we go any further out to say
this podcast is sponsored
by the fleshlight fleshlight go to Joe
rogan.net and click on the link and say
15% that we have a real sponsor.
We have to like really pay attention.
You know what they need to do with those
is actually put a battery in them for
an actual light. Because
in, in, especially in this,
just see my loads glowing through.
Yeah. But you know where that is.
Even if it's hidden,
you know where that is.
And if your power goes out in your house,
you could probably get to that quicker
than a legitimate flashlight. Right.
Because let's say you haven't
been joy in lose. This, you know,
is if it's under some
books underneath the couch,
you know exactly where to
go to get a very good point.
I have no idea where any of my
flashlights, but you know where that is,
what that is. That's so true.
That's a good point, dude.
You know that actually
might be a legit product.
You might actually be able
to sell that to them. Yeah,
because they don't bring that up with
the fleshlight people in emergency
flashlights the back.
But people worry about shooting loads
and then getting battery acid on their
dick.
You know,
like something breaks and you get battery
acid just sprays out all of your balls.
But there's less of a chance
of getting battery acid there.
Then actually thrown into
some chicken meat and Vegas.
You probably have a better
chance of having something wrong.
Go down with the random chicken and
battery acid. Really? You think so?
Do you think,
uh,
a random chick is scarier than sticking
your Dick in some sort of a machine that
makes light out of a
battery? Jesus Christ, man.
Fucking laissez faire.
How lackadaisical and relaxing
color are you with your balls, man.
You're posting in your batteries.
The statistically probably there's a
better chance of getting something from a
random chick then to get
battery acid on statistically.
But that's because statistically over
the years a lot of people been fucking
random chicks. Not that many dudes
been sticking to Dixon battery holes.
Well not that we know that. We
know that there must be. So yeah,
there's gotta be some guy that spoke
girls, you know a couple of girls. What?
They've got battery acid or liver
JJ from vibrators. Oh yeah. Right.
Cause it's not the same thing if you
ever [inaudible] you tell him the truth
there.
There was a long time ago,
there was this girl I used to date back
in high school that used to have this
vibrator that was like the like she stole
from her mom who's mom stole it from
our grant.
It was the grossest vibrator ever.
And it was so cheap and plastic looking.
One time I was just looking at it and
was like, you have the dirtiest vibrator.
Cause we had like that this white powder
all around the the where the battery
was on the, on the side of it and
opened it up and it was just a blown up,
you know like those old batteries where
the acid just goes everywhere. She goes,
I never turn it on though and I'm like,
but look at this white stuff
all around it. Oh my God,
that white stuff is eaten
up or snap probably.
I mean like how horrible
these battery acid, if
there was a pawn star show we're
dudes brought in, that would be funny.
I would watch it.
I would like to see,
this is a vibrator I've had in my
family for like three generations.
My grandma had it and then they adapt
to bring that expert out to test it.
It'd be a tumble dildo tester and
this is a good quality. This was,
I've always touched
at battery acid by
mistake. Like, you know,
like you're taking an old
remote control and you're like,
God damn these batteries and he pulled
out and you're always looking at your
hands like, am I really supposed to be
doing this right now? Some nice car.
Some day sex toys will be like, they will
be like antiques that are fascinating.
Like if you find some Walras bone
dildo from the fucking French Alps,
it used to be in neanderthals. That
some fascinating shit man to us. That's,
that's really interesting.
Yeah.
I guarantee you like flashlights and
shit someday those things are going to be
like a big point of novelty
when they have like, you know,
three d holograms at suck your Dick when
they have some, you know what I mean?
I mean they're gonna have some crazy shit.
It's going to be just an a new experience
and artificial experience like wired
into your brain or micro robots.
Like it's a lotion that you put in your
vagina and like all these little baby
microscopic robots are formed a vibrate
certain ways and you could just use your
iPhone to like turn up the volume of the,
the vibration in my vagina jail.
You know what I mean? I don't think
it's going to be that complicated.
Go fucking microscopic robots inside your
pussy. I wouldn't trust him in there.
What if they decided not to leave and
you get some sort of a yeast infection or
that?
Yeah,
they start freaking out and they get
the virus and they start just slip.
They won't turn on you at first. The be
a friends. Everything we perfect. Yeah.
Then that's when he turn on me and we
just want to get better ways to get off.
You don't have to stick robots in your
posts. That's just me though, man.
I'm old school.
I'm simple when it comes to shit.
If you hear my voice you like,
Damn Joe, you saw I've got a cold.
I still do have a fucking cold.
This is so disappointing.
I've had a cold for over a week now.
This is a longest,
longest cold I've had in years. Man.
Me and John are about to get this cold.
So what is, what is the forecast
for you when you get this cold?
Gets is going to come about like next
Thursday you're going to start getting
sniffles. I mean, is that going to be
okay for you by next Thursday? Yeah.
That's cause that takes vitamin C and
sleep and you'll be fine. That'd be good.
It'd be on stage in New York going.
Where are you in New York? Uh,
Gotham when New Year's Eve. Oh,
New Year's eve in Gotham. Gotham's
a great club. I loved that place.
I love it because of the security
guys that are there. Everybody's cool.
They're employees. Those guys just have
a certain kind of coolness when boom,
people are kind of being douchey.
Former cops. Yeah. They go in,
they do this move where they just
put their hand on the guy's shoulder.
He don't say a word and then they just
walk away and then that guy doesn't get,
he doesn't get mad. Like other clubs
where Ian, great. Uh, shoulder move,
sort of like a Spock thing. Kind
of like, I'm not the only one here.
Notice I'm in a suit and so are these
other guys and we probably all have
weapons. Wow. All in one. One little
one little. That's a God damn pro.
One little. Yeah, that's a great
club. It is. It is. I love that club.
Love that quote. That's backdrop to
[inaudible] club. I think just, you know,
it's most of our clothes backdrop.
Walking to that club stand
up to the special there. Oh,
did he? Yeah. Yeah I did.
It's showtime special there and
really interesting background.
He had like mirrors in the background.
You remember it like a
reflection of themselves, like
an eighties dance club. It,
it looked like did it? Yeah. Yeah. It
looked like a couple bad. Yeah, I taught,
I thought it was just unusual. I didn't
think it looked like a ladies dance club.
So remind me of like a one night or you
used to have to do where the, you know,
I liked it. It's small though. I like
that, that it's all intimate like that.
I may be the way to go when
you're filming a special,
I mean everybody wants to do like a big
crazy special and the theater and I've
done that,
but it doesn't seem,
it's not the same kind of
show as the the the club show.
The club shows a different
show. Yeah, definitely both
fun. They're both different.
Like the laughs and the big theaters are
way bigger cause there's so many people,
it's just, you know when when you get
on a roll and gets pretty fucking crazy.
But at a theater there's,
for me there's like a little
bit of a disconnect because,
well one you just can't see the people.
It's not we're doing on purpose.
You just have so many lights.
You just,
as you literally looking out into the dark
on, well I hope I'm staring at people,
but you can't tell. Yeah, it feels
very strange. It feels almost like a,
like sort of an artificial show feels
like a fake show. You know? It's weird.
It's sometimes they get going though
and they feel just like a regular show.
I've had giant places that feel like a
regular show sometimes just because of
the mood is right. It's like it works
out or you're at a small, you know club.
It's in the basement somewhere that has
a hundred people in that show feels,
I don't shows a crazy I did, uh, your,
your, your favorite place in Michigan.
Ann Arbor comedy showcase where I started.
That's a great place. First place ever.
We were there for the UFC and this place
is like an hour away from whether UFC
was but uh, mean a cigar did shows
there and fuck was a great club.
Perfect size. It's like 250 seats. He
like a comedy club. You're in a basement.
Yup. And then you can literally touch
without even extending your arms. I'm off.
There's something about those rooms,
man.
Those intimate rooms when you're onstage
and it hauls connecting and everyone's
having a good time and the materials
just coming out smooth and everyone's
laughing. It's like, man,
it's like some crazy energy.
It's the same if you ever walk into an
older house that was built a long time,
you know, an older house in a
neighborhood, there's an energy about it.
Then you walk into somebody's house
who lives in one of those prefab new
subdivisions and it's a different energy.
I think it's the same thing when you
feel like it's been lived in dwelt in
comedy club at mall where it,
it doesn't have that same whatever
that thing is. Yeah, that is,
I mean I guess you could recreate that
if you just had a real good environment,
but you're right.
All the new cool spots,
like even new cool spots to just open up
in la like, wow, what a great, cool spot.
Even if it feels cool, there's
something missing. Those,
those older clubs like the
comedy works in Denver,
Denver and also in a basement and he was
exonerated as a theme is it says photos
punch low in Atlanta. I just tricked by
photos. Maybe you're just like, oh my God.
So much head shots in my head and my
place has a lot history. Totally be.
Stoner talk might totally be stoner.
Talk. Absolutely. But you know, there's,
there's people that believe there's
certain like scholars that actually have
proposed
that the concept that everything
has a type of memory. You know,
Rupert Sheldrake experiences,
I think he's an evolutionary biologist.
I think that's what he does.
But he, um, had this um,
concept that everything has memory,
like tables and chairs.
They all have some sort of memory came
out to your table having memories.
I'd be like, God damn, I look
at that table's memories.
They carry like a certain,
the certain weight of their experience.
Although the environment
they've been around,
the idea is that when you're giving
off bad energy or good energy,
anything that's going on,
like the things around you pick it up.
That's why when you go to, I mean the
eye, it's totally more total hippy doc.
But if you go to someone's house
and they're like really cool,
like their whole house feels cool,
it feels like friendly, you know?
Did you ever go antique shopping?
It's kind of creepy and it's not just
like looking at regular furniture.
You're going through the shit that was
owned by somebody. It's probably dead.
And then you get to a box of old photos
of people's like wedding photos and
stuff that are just, you know, there's
no kids that took them, you know,
so are just miscellaneous people's
photos from like the 20s and stuff.
I'll buy a couple and just like look at
him and like draw mustaches on them and
throw them away and stuff. But there are
only like 25 cents. You should go there,
go to an antique store, find the
box of old photos. It's freaky.
That's all I had to say.
Wow.
Yeah. Old Pictures of weird man. The, the
idea that they just captured some person,
you know,
it's like we were so connected today
that just the concept of the way people
lived in like the,
the late 18 hundreds early 19 hundreds
like that's so alien to us. Just the idea.
So when you see a photo of someone from
like some fucking dude who was trying to
make it across the country with his kids,
you know from the wild west from like
1865 and you see a photo of the dude and
he like walked off, fuck, look
at that guy. That guy was just,
he was almost some sort of an animal,
you know?
I mean [inaudible] no fucking cell
phone. No cable. What did he learn?
Some Shit in school. What did they
even know then? Did they know anything?
I mean they were one step removed from
thinking that people would get in a boat
and fall off the face of the earth.
These motherfuckers that came over here,
those, the settlers like Jesus. When you
see a photo of them and their family,
hard looking people out there in the
woods and you knew eventually there
probably got fucking scalped
by Indians. Yeah. Like whoa.
That's a crazy ass picture.
Could you imagine if somehow or another
you got fucking transported back in time
and you had to live in the old
cowboy days? No. Fuck. Only the, the,
the prostitutes would be good I think. I
think that would be clean. Prostitutes.
Are you kidding me? You get
nothing is clean. No pregnant.
All regular girl smelled like
dirty prostitutes back then. Yeah.
I forgot about processes.
Powdered wigs and be kind
of cool to be disgusting.
Those women must have been just rancid.
It must have smelled like animals
just found this.
No one's shaving their legs.
They're barely survive and they're
eating dirt sandwiches every day.
They're out there in the fucking dust
taking baths. I what? They're like
entertainment tonight or extra wide. Like
they had the gossip about random crap.
They didn't know that they
were missing the Internet.
They didn't know that they were missing,
you know,
stuff because it didn't exist
in their head. So they weren't,
so they all had to just socially was
it just my only references are like
tombstone when they go to that dance.
Yeah. They'd go to the billiard hall.
I remember they played pool and they
would like get mad at each other and shit.
I remember Kevin Costner and Wyatt Earp.
Yeah.
But I guess you're just complain
about like, boy these, these,
if you've seen these new horseless
carriages, they're not gonna you know,
I guess you would have those guys,
the haters and the,
Oh I don't think the horseless carriage
just came around for awhile and I was
like I'm those actually going to be off
on a lot of it rubbed her I lifetime and
when competing at anything that I have
a whole generation or three. Yeah.
What,
how many years is officially a generation?
Cause I always like to
think of it as lifetimes.
I don't think like generations are too
fucking confusing. Like you know what?
How many, how many years do you fall
into, you know, tactically it's 10 kids.
He always invent new names for the new,
is it 10?
But then if I can go look my dad's,
yeah, I think so. It's officially here.
This is definitely officially a new
generation because people will always talk
to me about someone who I have no idea
who the fuck they are and they act like I
should know this person is, you know,
like some famous singer or some famous,
you know, rapper or whatever
the hell it is. Yeah.
I'm at that age where whatever band is
on like a late night talk show. Yeah.
Yeah. Used to go, oh cool. These guys. And
they're like, hmm. Two don't know anybody.
Yeah. I don't know anybody. It's crazy. I
watch, you know, dancing with the stars.
I'm like, who is this watch? Who is this
guy? I watched an episode the other day.
Why did I like dancing? Joe?
Hi. Um, no, I don't like,
but you did dance furthers that
the upcoming movie movie. Yeah.
You kind of got the little dancing. A
flavor dance fever. Yeah, I got it yet.
No Man. That the rhythm catch him. The
rhythm caught on that rhythm. It was hard.
Dancing is difficult. It requires a
lot of focus. Like, well, we had to do,
I forgot what it's called,
some Spanish thing,
but it's like a big fucking serious
like bullfighting fucking dance.
It's like they throw their chest forward,
arms back,
and the dude who like was typing in,
punch out the dude who was like teaching
me how to do the mail moves was this
dude. He was like this bad house
dancer and I'm like, you know,
this is like something really hard to
do that you get like zero credit for,
and they're like, dudes don't give a
fuck that you're in really good dancer.
You know they, they're like,
part of them is like, yeah
man, that's awesome man. Wow,
you been incredible.
Then part of them was like,
why the fuck are you spending all your
time doing this? What are you doing?
Fruitcake? Just spinning around the
music that got his shit together. Yeah.
It's weird that that guy learns
all those dance moves in Britain.
Probably hundreds of moves within a song,
but then we give a lot of credit to a
basketball guy who can you go over here,
post out and then turn to the left?
That's all. You know what I mean? Well,
there's some one ones or something
to fund this. I mean, I guess, look,
there's something to all of it.
There's something to fun dancing and then
something to this as like some sort of
a,
a visual performing arts sort of a thing.
It's definitely a different experience,
but it's a lot of fucking work.
I have ballroom dance one,
two and three in college.
It's a lot of work and the final result
is not interesting to me. No, it's fine.
I don't care. I dated a girl who
was, I get big dancing. Chuck,
you're at the Brown Derby here in town.
Whenever I first moved to La and she
taught all these ballroom Nancy's and then
we went to some club that just
played normal music. Oh No.
She didn't know how to dance.
And she like, no, I don't
know. It had to be one, two,
three, four, one, two, three, one, two.
Like you're banging some
crazy robot broad. But yeah,
but you think that because she knew
18 south of dance that you know,
we get on the dance floor,
you know, hearing, you know,
you guys love snapping
power and says I love it.
We didn't talk about,
we weren't talking about where we're
going to have our second chance prompts.
Awkward moment ever is when they see like
in Vegas about five dudes hanging out
together and there's no girls Nero and
they're getting a couple of drinks in
them and they start sort
of like half dancing.
They can't like totally commit to dancing,
you know,
so like little go through
like half the moves.
Like I'm not really in the fuck of this
music when it doesn't make me move that
much.
But you know,
I'll give a little move or get with
a little move here and the, you know,
but they can't like dance with each other.
They can only move just some minimal
amount. You can't get crazy now.
You can't just sit in front of each
other, grow gyrating hips. This is,
you're not allowed to do that to dudes.
Girls can get together and dance
all they want, but with dudes,
you can only sort of half dance. I used
to go just by myself. Yeah. Sometimes.
Sometimes just to go out by yourself
to clubs. Um, when I first moved to La,
I did really, I would go on the
dance floor by myself. Oh my God.
There's something wrong with your
brain and you need to go to a doctor.
At first it's a little bad.
At first you,
you're going to get the guys that are
like, look at it. What's this guy doing?
You kind of do,
but then you get the girls that come
over to you because they liked the guy
who's then. We've done a lot of
work. Yeah, it did look, got tea.
I think it was a very gutsy,
gutsy move. Not always worked.
How many times does it failed
on you? Oh, I don't even know.
Probably more times than, but, but it
just takes that one time, you know,
just that one time.
Some dudes can take criticism or rejection
rather. Some dudes are fine with that.
I have a friend, he would, he
would hit on every girl that,
he was an ugly guy and he was fat,
but he didn't give a fuck who would swing.
He would swing at every pitch.
I know a couple of never known
that way that he's a comic. Yeah.
I don't want to give them up on the air.
I've owned you do mine either,
but you can't go to bars with that
guy because it's, it's too much too.
Those are always the guys who let
people know you're a comic. Like,
like there's a whole bunch
of comics that are that way.
So they go up to the volunteer, they, hey,
where's the comics had to chuck a hut
and then the bomb to usually like,
I don't care.
It's not what you want for,
or they want the girls to be
impressed. It's back. It's brutal.
When you with a dude will,
you know, there's no way.
If you go somewhere and there's a chick
that he's not going to hit on her and
then it's not going to get annoying and
it's not going to get embarrassing. Yeah,
those guys are brutal. Or,
you know, it's like, okay,
I can't hang out with you anymore because
if I hang out with you and we'd go
somewhere, you look immediately. Just
everything that moves the first fucking,
the waitress comes over. I think she's
kind of, Oh man, look at that target.
And then the next thing, no, all,
it's all about this fucking waitress
and him getting this waitresses number.
I'm like, Whoa, why can't you
just have lunch fucking Weirdo.
And then they don't come to your table
anymore because they don't want to deal
with Ya. And then, yeah, exactly.
And it because it works every 30th time.
They fucking just want to put in those
numbers, man. Yeah. Those crazy dudes,
they just want to put in those numbers.
And if you're around them, you're like,
oh great. It's embarrassing. Yeah,
it's fucking disastrous, man.
It's a shitty feeling.
I would, uh, gather move when I was on by
myself. I would go up to girls and say,
my friends left me.
Can I dance by you?
So I don't look like I'm dancing by myself
and low. Then you dance. But here's,
here's the trick, young
guys. Here's the thing,
you have to commit to that and you don't
talk to those girls. You don't go, can I?
Bebo and then, Hey, what's up ladies?
Then you ignore them. OOO, okay.
And then the cooler, one of the group will
then kind of come over and go, you can,
and then they'll let you into the circle
if you're not completely hideous and
embarrassing them.
The key is,
is not to give them attention
after you do that little move. Wow.
And then now you're the
hurt animal in the forest.
You're the bird with a broken wing.
And there'd be one nurturing girl in that
group that will bring you in. And yeah,
I just go up to him and go, Hey, I'm a
producer. I like, or moves, uh, ladies,
I just want you to just stop and
think about how fucking gross men are.
Have you heard a bang brothers?
I started, I stop for a second.
And think of how gross
men are and how fucking,
how much effort you put into creating
the perfect environment where they think
you're a nice guy or interesting or
mysterious or cute or whatever the fuck
you're doing.
How much of most most guys,
every day focus is just to
try to get girls to log them.
94, 4% of the day. Yeah,
that's Brian.
Bri gets off for like fuck you
mean Brian has no loads left.
Masturbation and girls.
He's got no loads left.
He's got no time for your bullshit.
White fucking around. John,
why are you fucking around man?
So these girls get stupid with it.
Like I have no loads for you.
You're dancing plan.
You just need to hit it out the fat.
You,
you spend too much time with that dancing
plan. And what is your dancing plan,
Brian? You just go up to
him. Go, Hey, am I producer?
What do you produce here? I'll play the
girl. I'll play the girl. Ready. Hi.
Hi. Uh, so I'm a producer.
Oh Wow. What do you do?
What do you produce? What do you
do? I'm like, actress. Sorry.
Wait tables right now.
I went on this call back.
I'm pretty sure it's gonna work.
Produce a, Hey, you got Facebook?
What do you produce? Oh my
God, I shouldn't give this.
All right, I'll do it here. Let me
type it in for you. Oh, what's your,
what's your passcode? Uh, Tom,
I'm not gonna remember this.
Okay. Do one to two. What can you
say that louder? All right, cool.
All right. See, I'm just gonna turn
it on your mobile. Me Right here.
And location services. All right,
cool. Cool in here. All right, cool.
There.
There's my face whip.
Whoa.
Stun a dumb checks. I'm
like, what the fuck is magic?
I'm dating Joe Wizard.
Uh, that girl used to date a
long time ago. Uh, Jessica,
the first thing I said to her,
she was playing with her iPod and we
were all out to dinner. And I go, Hey,
let me rephrase it. Your iPod for you.
She goes, what is it running slow?
And I'm like, yeah, let me refragmented
for you. And I took it in the night,
did all this stuff. And I'm like, there,
it should be running a lot faster now.
And she goes, wow, I didn't even know
you could do that. What's your name?
And that's how we, so what did
you actually do? You did nothing.
Now I just kind of,
I forget what I know.
What's shitty taste in music.
She has been some mother fucker.
All these Bob Seger song.
Yeah,
La Cool Rock Zack
got from that commercial. I never
danced to the songs from the commercial.
That's where I know it from.
That guy was a bad mother
fucker back in the day.
There's certain certain dudes when the
well runs dry it, they, they, they,
their music is like so different.
You know, like perfect examples.
Billy Joel,
Billy Joel is like one of the biggest
turnarounds ever from like a guy who was
like this young guy who had this,
these really passionate lyrics
and it was really interesting.
Like songs that really like
moved you to uptown girl.
She's been living, you know,
it's like in that eight. Yeah,
something happens where they
just hit the fucking rocks.
Whether it's love, it's too much
love. You know what I'm saying?
Or too much hot chicks sex, you know, like
they've got it all now. It's like this,
the passion in the anger,
it's,
it's not there anymore because now
they're banging supermodels and they drive
and fucking Ferrari's and living
in mansions. So where's all,
where's all that struggle,
you know? And what's tricky,
your struggle, John? My struggle
right now. What are you,
what have you been struggling with lately?
John's got many struggles that he
can't talk about in the air. Brian.
We both know this. I have my roof
leak in. Your roof is leaking. Yeah.
That's a big one of those people.
What's better?
Your roof leaking or the roof is on fire.
Fucking Rufus on leaking.
We don't need no water.
Yeah.
Have you heard the new Eminem
song with Little Wayne?
Little Wayne is already making
songs. Yeah, he's already,
I'm just going to jail.
We could go. Yeah. And he's got like
three videos. Peppers make me feel lazy.
They put together a lot of work. Yeah.
Well you should. M and M has some
lyrics in this one that are awesome.
What's his name? Little Gym. Literally.
Yeah.
He's a sausage maker from Chicago.
Jim Little Wayne. What
is it? I don't know.
Wayne Little Wayne with a,
it's called no love.
Little Wayne is a sign of the times.
My favorite new mnm lyric is I'm going
to stop being mean when Aquaman drowns in
human flame swims. Wow. That's not
good wine. That's not that good.
Why can't, well, yeah,
and so it's a m and M and who else?
A little Wayne Little Wayne did.
Both of them are really mad. They're
mad. They're looking. Holy Shit.
He woke up and they were really
mad. Wow. This is a brand new song.
Just came out while they took 'em.
Yes.
Everybody hears evidence and
little Wayne is that sure. No.
Who's the where they sampling?
What is, what is? Wow. Flour.
What is fuck the water.
Get it. Shout Louder. Yeah.
My life was bitch,
but you know net bow.
Then the hail packet show you.
I wrote this minimum comes into,
I'm smoking sour maverick game,
but she broke up bow.
That's why my bars of full of
broken bottles and my nightstands,
I'll follow open Bible App.
Think about more than Affleck get,
but down go around Phi expected not to
sweat and these Niggas know Adelaide come
on beat.
Just try to keep the commandment of down.
I think that's prison talk [inaudible]
him problems on the triple beam.
I'm sticking to the script you need
Nigga. Skip. Hey uncomfortable.
No phone. That guy. Fuck. Get
right at. Got My guns sent me.
Taught a man.
Hope this gets better soon.
I know what got my names coming up next
up. All right. Can I be skipping down way,
man.
Yeah.
That's not good.
Going up. Everybody's got
their own tastes man. But
here comes and UK. Here we go.
I like where this is going.
[inaudible] my whole entire life.
But can you see these people's ears per
cup? Miss, begin a spat with the pin.
I haven't set a bit sick of him.
Mostly it's been to get the ticket.
Can they say to the competition is stiff,
but I get a hot dick from the SIP.
Now stick it in. I never driven in kings.
Cross into the wind. Complete freedom.
Look at these battles. How treat
them. So my phone when I joined them,
when I beat him,
hey call me a freak because I like
Tom Smith on these policies for IOM.
Get these black cock suckers
state where the puck is concave.
When you need someone to
to finish in a minute,
get it baffles type that motherfucker
he is thinking might want to go back to
the land tonight and Oh Geez,
we've them Ramzi with bonus fit and start
off the who tracks and find new words
but I'm afraid today ain't gonna make
no difference whatever with the stadium.
Teva didn't have to back to them in
detail based on the place to look.
Crank that backup set box at a bike
and at night the crowd you can see them
spots from Ron [inaudible] from mudafo
torn of the game of Saul started at
Mcdonald's with a back,
even in the harshest you can still get
rusty custom Austin [inaudible] from the
top. I'm not going to start
a home stay in macbook.
Napoli Bullock that needs a double top
took monk came in its own sound and some
I get tone when you self go down to Cape
Town because at 80 but cool for you to
sound cocky anymore.
People just get sick because 50 full
cape rule at Tripler drop anymore and you
can have a break.
Must drive.
You have a slow the momentum at 85 minute
block of glove in order to take top
prime chairman of close the Vinton minium.
Palomita getting don't mercy mark mill
works in. Let not relating to staff.
No flies on Dropbox cheap given them
hell women's who when a famine needed now
plus you get those Lau [inaudible]
work to save his throat until
[inaudible] Randy incident.
[inaudible] new
[inaudible] [inaudible] [inaudible]
now here's where I am. Last Christmas
that was eminent. More no love ambulances,
a bad motherfucker. This album is
called recover a little company.
It's awesome.
I think it's probably one of his best.
He's got such an unusual flow,
you know,
he's never not pumps me up. Like even
if I don't, I'm like, wait, what?
What'd he say? I just, it's really his
right. It's like that's his shit. Yeah.
You know,
it's like he's got a real original way
of making shit rap and rhyme or making
Shit Ryan. And when he, when he hits that
flow man, it's like, it's so compelling.
Yeah. I tell her to do is
I couldn't listen to them.
Yeah. It's driving me crazy.
But when m and m came on,
I'm like, God damn, this dude
is a master. I wonder here.
And that type of music that
just to meet his jazzy,
you just want to start hitting stuff.
How many people fake UFC
walking music in their bedroom?
Like grown adults? Like when, when the
music's playing, the kind of, you know,
the kind of getting that little
hopping. I do it. Do you do it?
Who you pretend to walk out
like you're about to walk out.
That'll be a really funny
scene in a movie, Dude.
I have a fake walk out to a fight.
Wow.
Because I got to sing when I'm ironing
before show where after you don't want to
get toto.
I put in music and then a miring and then
that kicks and then before you know it,
you've got something wrong with you
man. Boxing around doctors, it's twice.
I think you've got to go to a brain
doctor. Sorry. Going to clubs by yourself.
That was when I was like 20 something
I didn't want to go to karaoke with.
And then standing in front of the mirror
pretending like big John McCarthy's
fucking checking your cop fucking Weirdo.
I do do the Tito Ortiz hop sometimes that
when you bounce light in your house by
yourself, like when am
I earning and when? Oh,
when I get jazzed by the music you get
fired up and then you're kind of in those
boxer briefs.
They guy.
You kind of liked the fight shorts that
you go through these stages where you
get into martial arts training
and you do it for awhile.
You do a Krav Maga for a while. He
did. You do to for awhile. And when,
what are you doing now? Are you doing
anything? Uh, I've been doing this a,
I think she's an ex porn chicks.
A workouts on body rock.
Go to body rock.tv. I tell you
it's your new thing. Shake weights.
No, you have to check out this website
and see how hard the workouts. Oh,
I'm sure man. People goof
on. You know those just step
type in in a row. Clusters.
Those fucking things are hardest shit,
man.
I've been doing it in shape girl lately.
It's like these ribbons and sticks.
It's an exercise thing. It
really helps me out. My cash.
What the fuck you ever see?
They get in shape, girl fro?
What does it get in shape?
I used to be this exercise thing for
kids in the 80s with ribbons and sticks.
It's kind of funny that they can
have women's only gyms, but you,
they'll bitch at you if you
try to have a men's only Jim,
you can't have like a Menzel in gym.
You can have those curves and shit
like that where women can't go,
but you can't even even boxing gyms,
women go to the boxing gym,
so I think even have to have a male
and female locker room or bathroom.
Actually you could have a co because they
do that in Hollywood. They have a coed,
which is horrible because then
girls have to go in there.
I have to do is take giant, stinky.
Yeah. I liked that sub separate. Yeah,
you should have stuff separate. You
don't want to smell my shit hooker Joe,
you should. You should bring a guy
only Jim and cut instead of curves.
Call it like bulges or something
like all's bulges. Hairy balls.
So I've been doing the body rock.tv.
You have to check it out fellas.
Gonna you getting paid for this? Is this
a sponsoring your website? Because it is.
I'll throw up in your lap 100% of that,
but you should see the
girl who was on there.
That's what I'm trying to give you guys.
More nos filled with hot chicks so you
could look at them anytime you want on
the Internet. You don't have to
work out to them. Um, and then,
then I was going through
a phase where I'm like,
there's a do you do to plays
right across the street from me.
We're at just literally it where I live.
Well you have to go and it's right
there. And I'm like, well maybe I'll go.
And then I saw um,
video,
some guy doing a reverse arms
lock or something. I'm like,
maybe I'll just do judges.
So I go on phases where like I just,
I don't want anybody punching me
anymore. Well, the Jujitsu thing,
the good thing about that is that it's,
you don't have to do striking
grappling enough to worry about it.
You'll get hit anyway.
You're always going to get hit.
You're going to get headbutts. So people
slammed and listen, you're accidentally,
it just,
things always get hit,
but it's not like the thing that impressed
me when I was um, doing this guid.
You do too, that there's a
guys in there that was like 60,
65 in probably more way more flexible
than me or containing young guys on a,
that's cool thing about rolling
around like that is the older you get,
you never have to leave it.
You're Jane might slow down a little bit,
but very technical martial arts,
very technical,
like I roll a lot of times
with guys who are way,
way lighter than me and weaker than me,
and yet they can still tap me. You know,
there's, there's not too many sports
like that where someone who's bigger,
stronger, faster, more agile than you,
and yet you could still contain them.
You know? I mean, if you're playing
football and even if you're like,
there's no one on one football or one
on one basketball, even if you're like,
you know,
fairly talented.
If a dude is very fast and very athletic
and much quicker and stronger than you,
he's probably gonna fuck with you.
It's probably going to fuck you up.
But in Jujitsu, it's amazing what like
a light person can do to a big, strong,
heavy person. There's a Fred,
Felicia, Felicia, oh, do you
know Felicia? She's, Whoa,
what a John Jacques Machado
is black belts. Yeah.
That's where she's a great person.
She's really, you know, an excellent,
like legit black belt. Well, this Guy
Seymore butts. You know who he is?
The porn star. I used to have that
TV show. I forget what it was.
It was a showtime show.
Oh, it's cause demos? No,
it was the showtime show about him.
Something about him. Anyway, uh,
he wanted to film an episode where he
learn Jujitsu and then rolled with the
girl. So he came to Eddie's
class. He learns all these moves,
learns when an Armbar is law firms with
a triangle is and they gave him like a
couple of private lessons and then he
rolls with Felicia on camera and Felicia
just commences to strangle him in
every way, shape or form. She wants to,
she arm bars him, triangles m takes his
back. I mean she just fuck's this dude.
I had no chance. It was like
just a, just a total mangling.
She mangled him and I think they put
very little of it if any of it on the
television show.
He didn't want to be embarrassed but he
stopped doing it because I would say a
dual, I was saying about Jujitsu or either
knife fighting or let's be realistic.
Cain fighting. They get, stop
all that. Go to Ju Ju Jitsu, man.
What did I just give you an inspirational
speech about 130 pound woman
strangling a male porn star to death too.
If she fought him to the death,
she would have won.
He'd be a dead man and
she'd be standing over him.
I will with his fucking head in her hand.
She fucking finished him.
Wouldn't it be cool to take like a
Chinese stars like class to become really
good at it? To make it like at like a
boomerang where you can just go, yeah,
and then someone pulls out a gun.
This is Jesus Christ.
Why not get good at fucking
cannon bolts and no,
this is what you need to get
a sling and a really cause.
That's how David Killed Goliath.
But what if he's throwing knives?
If you got really good at it, you do. When
you eat a gun, it's heavy. They're sharp.
Carry a gun. You couldn't beat a
gun. You could. No, you didn't.
He got so good he could hit the guy right
in the vein in his superhero. Come on.
Fuck it. Goddamn kind of looks good
now you're just making up rules.
Silly Dude.
I think that does pull that fucking
fill full of bullet holes. Show
you guys one day.
This is the beginning of
kickass three bread pan returns.
What's wrong with you? Boy, that's what I
want to know. What is wrong with you? Uh,
it's,
it's pretty smart if you think about it.
I mean if it's a knife with five corners,
it's like a star of night. You've got to
keep them in a pouch so they don't stab,
you know, you go to get them out rather
obvious man purse thing on the side.
Oh and a million in there. Yeah.
Okay. Okay. I see what you're saying.
I saw like a thought this
through a belt buckle.
Chinese star and like Black Belt
magazine you could get, yeah.
He sat down to Brian wants to be a
character in a Spiderman comic book.
You did not. You did not order Chinese
starts as a kid. Yeah, definitely.
Pretty bad ass Dorn comes you're way
better. They're way better. Yeah.
But if you get pulled over with a gun,
it's a little bit different.
If you got pulled over with a bunch
of trying to catch up with, yeah.
You know what the difference is?
You can have a license for a
gun and you could buy Chinese.
Chinese starts like what the fuck
you and nanny shows or legal. Yeah,
they're sort of are they?
Yes.
You can know by the
Chinese stars at the mall.
Samurai sword. There's some laws to those
things. Shiny stars. No, there's no laws.
I don't think so. Not In California.
At least there wasn't in Ohio.
I know there wasn't in Ohio. I haven't
looked into Chinese start either way.
They're going to think there's something
wrong with what he can't have it in
your pocket. Cause that would
be a concealed weapon. Yeah.
But if you have a big clear Ziploc bag,
like you go to the airport,
he starts,
I do need you, but you're kind
of a poured Ninja. So yeah,
you have to keep it in a Ziploc bag.
You know you don't really,
you didn't have all the cool Ninja
stuff. You got problems kid. Both.
Both of you together, make dual
appointments, go to the brain doctors.
You think baths are really that
much worse than taking showers?
Like if you were to take a bath
everyday and scrub every day,
do you think it's worse? I mean your
showers are a hundred times better, right?
Well, the problem with baskets that you're
in the same goddamn water that doesn't
rinse off. If you took a bath and
then took a quick shower afterwards,
that's the move. Right? But line in your
own filth and you just, it's like t.
That's what it's like. It's like
butthole tea. Yeah, that's hot water.
Your butthole,
your balls,
all that is all run your face now and
you dunk your head under notes on your
forehead. It's all butthole and
balls. Tea. That's what it is. Yep.
And soap and dirt and
skin. No, it's stupid.
You ever meet those girls
that only take baths?
They didn't take their pussy butter.
That's gross.
I don't want to smell your feet either.
You need to take God
damn shower I clicker.
It's 2010 almost 11 get your shit
together, John. You and check.
Check this out. I went to the ghetto
washing machine the other day at best buy.
This shows you how bad best
buy's been getting lately.
Lately I've been going to best buy
and looking at like Kodak camp,
there's this camcorder that I got off
Amazon for like $175 right then and I
noticed that they always have
it there for $250 and I'm like,
why is that such a price
difference than Amazon?
I went to get a washing machine yesterday,
five 99 $599 I was about to pay for it,
but then I read lasered the price tag
thing on what does that mean? Red Lasers,
that application where you at scans the
UPC code and shows you how do you do it?
It's an application on your iPhone. What
do you do? You took a photo it, yeah,
well you pull it out and it opens it and
point it towards the UPC symbol and it
scans it and finds any local
places that has this product,
any online places and gives you all
the information about whatever product
you're scanning. So I'm about to
tell this guy, I'm like, all right,
I want this washing machine,
500 $599 fine, whatever.
That's a good washing machine.
And I scan it right at the last second
and it was two 99 at Sears and free
shipping. So they were like, oh,
I guess we'll price match that.
And they gave me free shipping and I
got done the washing machine half off.
Do they have to price match that?
They, that's one of their policies.
Best buy price matches everything. And
then just last week the Internet, Huh? No,
no, no. It has to be a local retail around
you, but they also just drop their fees.
Like when best buy was notorious.
Every time you bought something
and then you return it,
they always charge you like
10% 15% restocking fees.
The other day they just stopped that.
So there's no more restocking fees.
They're trying to, you know,
compete with Amazon and stuff.
But then you see these products lately,
like how the fuck are you?
That's 50% more than Sears.
They're just hoping that nobody
notices. Exactly. Exactly. Yeah.
Well back in the day when they say we are,
we'll give you the guarantee.
They knew nobody was going to check.
That was probably safe.
But now that you have
phones and you can go, okay,
I'm going to pull it up right now.
That's incredible.
You've got to adjust that red
tacting see things like that alone.
Make the iPhone and even droids
you can do that with two it. Yeah.
I mean this is like some
fucking futuristic shit,
man. Getting was incredible.
Yeah. You can take a photo
of the, the price tag,
it scans it and finds those fucking
objects in local markets refuse and every,
it's amazing the between that
in the fucking that Shizam Shit.
When you're at a restaurant and you
press that thing and it picks up the song
and tells you where the song
has let you buy the song,
let you watch it on youtube instantly.
Cause you young kid,
you didn't know what it's like where
you'd have to walk into a record place or
[inaudible] place and go up to the guy.
Do you guys have that one song that goes
[inaudible] imagine going with that m
and m song, not being able to figure out
what it is going to a to a CD stone go.
Do you ever when he goes [inaudible]
[inaudible] or something like that or no,
do it again to this guy [inaudible] I
remember there was places where you could
go where you can sample them. I
don't know what, what was it, virgin?
I think it was virgin.
You would go and you'd put headphones
on and they would have this specific CD
knew you'd be listening to tracks. So you
would always be waiting like God damn,
I can't get in one of
these fucking headphones.
All these greedy people keep
listening to every song.
So some people would just
stand there for hours.
There was sitting there for hours just
listening to album after album cause they
had them all up.
They're available to listen to and
that's how you'd find enough shit was any
good. So you take, I'm thinking
about taking a chance on this CD.
Let me listen to do it. And you'd go up
to the little station and listen to it.
Yeah. Which wasn't that long
ago. No, no, you're, yeah, we're,
you're talking less than 10 years.
Not even.
Probably you talk about a
fucking business has been trans.
I don't know if this is a true fact,
but talk about a business has been
transformed. I was looking on the, uh,
OMG facts on,
on Twitter,
and it said that 90% of all
music is downloaded illegally.
Yeah. That's crazy. Cause I buy
every single thing that I get. Yes.
But you make good money.
You're, you're successful.
I want to know if you were hurting, I
could see the justification. I mean,
I could totally see it. If you're
broken, you're a fan of something.
I totally get it, man. I think
it's a gray as fuck area.
I don't think it's as simple as everyone
calls it stealing. I don't think it is.
I think it's ones and
Zeros and it's out there.
And I think that when people can
support you, they will support you.
And that kind of support I think is more
valuable voluntary support than people
who just can't fucking afford
to support you financially.
But they still like what you're doing.
So I see it both ways.
I totally see the pirates point of view
and I totally see the artist's point of
view. I don't think it's
a cut and dry issue, man.
What you're doing is you're giving out
information, you know, you're given out,
whether it's books or movies or it's,
if they enjoy it,
they're going to support it. If they can,
they're, they're going to support it.
You know? And it'll be like
an even proposition, you know,
when people can support
you and do support you,
well then the guy spent money
because he's a fan, you know,
and like you gave him some legit
shit and he wants to support you.
And that to me is a way better
exchange than he took the chance on.
I didn't like it. And you've got his
money anyway. I don't want that money.
You know, I want the money where you
know what the fuck you're getting. Right.
You know what I mean?
But that's not like for capitalism.
It's not the best strategy,
you know, unless you do,
a lot of people just got to figure out
new ways of working. I mean that's what,
you know, back in the day,
that's what Dane Cook did
with, I think his first album.
Right. He gave, he put it on the
Internet and gave it away for free.
And that's why everybody in
that age bracket at that time,
right when mp3s came out,
you had Dane cook stuff on there
cause he gave us and then look,
look what happened.
Let's see.
There's a big difference between us as
comics and music. The music industry,
the music industry is basically
nonexistent. It's gutted.
I mean they've lost so many
jobs and so much money for us.
See putting my stuff on like,
well I'm a fucking comic. I,
I'd go on stage and I talk. You know what
I'm saying? It's just me. I wrote it.
I sat down, I put it all together,
I performed it, you know,
a thousand times over the year and
then boom, there it is. You know,
it's like there's such a big
difference between that, that as a,
as a piece of performance and music,
whereas you've got producers,
you've got all these fucking people
that are involved in it. The band,
you've got all the, the drummer you
got the guy writes the music, got the,
the guy who writes the lyrics, they all
have to go together. They've got agents,
they all have separate agency,
all of separate managers.
And then there's a fucking record producer
production company that acts actually
put money behind this and advertise them
and build up an image for them and get
them on all these television shows and
there's a fucking machine behind this
brand and that machine just got,
it's supplied to money cut off.
It's like somehow or another,
there's a giant leak in their barrel.
They're barrel of wealth that
they had forever. I mean they had,
they never thought the record
industry would go away. Jesus Christ,
everybody's been pimping artists
forever from the Elvis days,
Beatles, the rolling stones, you name it.
People got rich as fuck off of selling
them. And now that shit has changed.
It's changed radically. It's why
the record industry's coming back.
They're bringing back lps that you know,
a best buy.
I saw they have a bunch of lps now, you
know, like give me record disks. Yeah.
Because that's something,
you know, even if you steal,
you're buying something right
with the music and you don't.
People have a record and it's a novelty.
It's a novelty to have to
look at like Dee aunt word,
Deann word became famous
entirely through the Internet.
They don't need anybody else.
They don't need anybody else. Man.
They have a giant loyal fan base
already and growing all the time.
Every day when people are passing their
videos around and passed her songs were
on, they could fucking make their
own shit. If they had a backer,
they had someone to print
up their, there's their shit
and sell it and then it's,
you know, arrange a deal with iTunes,
arrange a deal with, you know,
amazon.com and all those other
places that sell them online.
They don't need anybody. No. You
could do a new business. Yeah.
Especially even your comic.
You could literally with some
small technology record your thing.
And have it up on iTunes in a day or two.
I wonder what the numb the
numbers on iTunes are though.
I wonder like what like
a really good selling,
like you know CD is on iTunes.
I believe they sell.
I was listening to a as if
it's 90% you know? Yeah.
It was just in a w train was talking on
a radio show and they were saying the
bad thing is let's say you,
you like some band and you have to buy
the whole album and then that would make
huge album sales.
But now if you only like the one song,
people are just going to
go get into one songs.
You're not really selling a lot of good.
That's because a lot of your
songs are wack as fuck son.
I need to get back to the drawing board,
get some stronger hash before
you put out your shit. Yeah man.
How many times have you gotten cds
in the past and where it was like,
there was like a couple of jam and
songs and there were some songs.
It looks like they just slapped that
bitch together to fill to most of them.
The worst is when you,
there was that one's got that one band
had a great song that hit and most of the
time their whole CD was just awful songs.
[inaudible]
the time. Uh, ice cream castles.
The only album because that was at the
time there were there five songs on that
album and a thinking back.
I'm like,
I paid full money for that when I was
that age and the only get five songs,
there's less than 20 minutes. Brian
Find Morris Day and the time. Cool.
Because I'm cool dude.
[inaudible] Morris Day and the time.
Cool. This is one of my favorite songs.
When I was a kid,
I loved Morris Day.
I was always sad when Morris Day just
did not get the recognition I felt he
deserved to me. He was mad aging
personality and he's very interesting.
I like the, I just holds the
mirror Jerome. Yeah, Jesse.
Yeah.
Listen to this shit.
This is from,
what year is this baby?
I have no idea.
You've got to put on my NASA space
goggles for this. This is great.
Welcome to the decimal.
A club. Cup it up like,
Hey, this isn't the right song dude.
Like the intro that he doesn't say cool.
This is not the right song. Boys
Day at a time to walk. Orion. Yeah.
What's the name of the sidewall?
C. O. L. E. W. J. L. B.
I just wanted to get you guys warmed
down. Here it is bro. Turn though.
This song is one of my all time
favorites. It's not. It's not.
The library was. Please don't do it.
Go back and do it to me. Here we go.
We'll try that. No, by the shit
on Itunes, man. Jesus. Boy.
I'm to hate. Is that station
that all the music's on now,
is that Vivio or whatever?
That's on youtube.
Vimeo and they make you watch commercials.
Here it is. Give me some volume.
This is probably like,
what is this like an 83
or you feel like 81 81
years old
to
the majesty.
It's got everything bro. [inaudible]
everything. He's got everything.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
he's just bragging.
That's the whole song.
He's just a bad motherfucker.
Don't get [inaudible] my time.
Just letting me know.
Driven everywhere
to
take me home.
Dozens.
Dude's got doesn't ring right here.
Heaven knows it.
[inaudible]
the the narcissist song to get one.
The greatest narcissists
song perhaps ever.
Although a little bit earlier we were
talking about three guys sitting around on
a dance floor. They couldn't really
commit, but during that song we were,
we were those three guys. I'll dance
right in front of Bitch. I ain't here.
You got the wrong guy. Brown wearing a
NASA suit would fuck it. Space Goggles on.
You don't think I'll dance in
front of you. Which by the way,
we were discussing before
when people travel,
they should have to wear those when I'm
wearing them from no one everywhere.
This was my fanny pack. That's how I'm
gonna move around the airport. Right.
When people know where I am,
I wonder if they get,
you get in trouble to think like you
look like you work for the airport or
something. You could just say this is
a fashion statement. [inaudible] Bro.
It's my travels.
Not like,
it's not like official government aren't
wearing this on stage from now on just
where Nasa Shit. We just think if you
only wore that for the rest of your life,
you'd never have to worry
about ever finding anything
else to wear it. Just that.
Yeah. But I don't want to be that guy,
dude. I don't want to be space. 1999 okay.
Why trying to sell me down that road?
John Heffrons want to
wear a fucking jumpsuit.
I don't want to work in an aviation plant.
I don't want what you guys get though.
Did you get ice cream
too, bro? We're from NASA.
We worked for an acid the whole time.
Reason I've been asked,
questioning the moon landings. I
am an agent of disinformation. I'm,
I'm here to make a doubter's look
foolish. That's what I do. Yeah.
And I just worked in human resources,
but
believe it or not, easier to keep me
alive. Try not say anything. So yeah,
I get a little bit crazy when I did
that wacky tobacky inside me and,
and they don't want me to represent the
company in a mostly sexual harassment.
But yeah, for him, I, I talk about black
cock and I stayed in his eyes, hey,
I don't think it's sexual harassment,
but for him,
whatever he gets nervous
happen once in space. Right.
Do you think sexual harassment and space,
can you imagine that if he
came back and the woman goes,
I would like to file a complaint.
We were up there.
If there was one camera that the the
astronauts didn't know about and then,
you know, get back to earth and
everybody, they're bringing my toe room.
Why do you want to explain what
the fuck this is all about?
They're all waitlists sucking
cock fly through, spinning,
rally air blowing each other.
I mean,
have you ever had sex experiments
up there? They had to off.
I'm sure it was off records, but
the Russians did it. The guy,
they probably can't help themselves.
They fuck those wild animals.
They're probably up there
just banging right now.
That was probably a pickup move.
Hey, I, this one's off the record.
Bob was supposed do sexual experiment
today. You know what? Honestly,
now that you brought this up,
I seem to remember that there was like
some sort of a debate on this recently
about where they were talking about people
having sexual relations in the space.
I'm going to have to Google that shit.
I wonder if they have banked.
That was an issue. They should have a
birth in space. That'd be Badass. Yeah.
But could, you know, dude,
it would not be everywhere in
with lists. Yeah, you could. Yeah.
I'd be like better than giving good for
the kid. There's no way. Yeah, dude,
you can't have a kid in the high altitude.
You know, when we, we had to get out of,
uh, the of the mountains mountains above
boulder because, uh, my wife was pregnant.
Imagine being a fucking space sex band
aboard the International Space Station.
They have banned sex. You can forget
joining the 200 mile high club
a cig out the Massa commander Alan
Poindexter told the reporter about the
concert, who asked about the consequences
if astronauts boldly went where?
Probably know others have been.
Okay,
what does that fucking Innuendo you bitch
ass politician that sexual intercourse
is not permitted. A board,
the International Space
Station, we are professionals.
Poindexter said we treat each other
with respect and we have a great working
relationship.
Personal relationships are not an issue.
He explained we don't have
them and we won't. Hm. Well,
what are you going to do when people go
in a space for like six months at a time?
That's the thing. If they ever decided
to like Malay shares, what does it flow?
Some shit to footloose guy of the space.
There'll be no dancing to be no sex in
dancing on this and I got base stations
for you. Well, the way I look at it,
that galaxy come through here. We,
so we're technically not on the feet.
Do Roots.
If you got dudes in a spaceship and
they're traveling six months to Mars,
they might start bawling in each other.
I got news for you.
Six months is a long ass time though.
Scientists might crack just a,
I'd be fine with six lines.
You would be the,
I think we both have some friends. That
would not be. It'd be like when we,
all right guys,
let's someone's,
someone's jerking me off and just tell
your story now before we go any further,
there's no big deal. Chokey comment. How
long can you only gave? It's on earth.
Both technically not on earth.
Close Your eyes and you pretend you're
making butter and I closed my eyes and
pretend you're a girl. That you're beefing
man. Like chimpanzee hand as a girls,
you're catalyst fucking thick fat fingered
knuckles as they pump up from my cock.
What Jeb? We talked about this in the
meetings. It's illegal by the way.
It's illegal. That's the thing. Now,
you know sex is banned aboard
the International Space Station.
So we answered her own question. Okay.
So if you're the two people that, that,
that you do have sex, then is there a
third that's going to be the snitch?
Probably was the land and the
guy that was going to San Sacks,
jealousy,
some bitch locker.
Poindexter this guy's name's
Poindexter coincidence. I think not.
Or if you did it, you did. That would be
the biggest story ever. Yeah. If I said,
well, why is, why is a
second space illegals?
I'm fucking Poindexter and you can't
tell me what I can do in space.
Sounds like Lee Lee.
That's like [inaudible] is Brazilian.
If we had Brazilians in space, they would
just start fucking, they won't even ask.
Did you ask questions?
Say, well, Tao Tao the bag.
We had set a precedent sphere
first doing it and there's banging.
Did you know astronaut's camp? Bourbon
space? Astronauts cannot burp and space.
And why is that? I don't know.
It's a fact though. Really? Oh,
it's not physically possible.
No, it's not physically possible.
You can be good to stay in space,
Huh?
That cannot be good for you
when you're at zero altitude.
Apparently it plays all sorts
of havoc with your bones.
Like your bones get real brittle
and shit. They get like, you know,
they get thin and you're, you lose all
your muscle because you're not resisting.
You know, it's like, yeah,
you, he come down to earth.
It's like you're all fucked up man. It's
like look, you've been in bed for a year,
you know, man, it's pretty crazy.
Like you have to like recover.
It takes a long ass time to recover.
Can imagine now you can't
cry on space properly.
So how the fuck are they ever going to
have it so that people can go, I mean how,
what's the longest that that a person's
been in a space station is like a year.
If they'd done a year up there by
themselves. Who's done the longest? No,
I have no idea. We should find
out how would they going to me,
cause like when you see like shows like
Battlestar Galactica and shit and people
are traveling across the galaxy
like a cool, it's like a mall.
It's like as you make gravity, do you
make fake gravity on the, on those ship?
Is that possible?
Can I do that?
Can you make fake gravity until they
make fake gravity? How the fuck that?
Fuck gravity with the jets. You how are
they free fall? Yeah. Or is that's fake.
No gravity. Right? We
need to do it backwards.
Or do you adjust it like the temperature
in the house so you can like go. It's,
there's a little too much gravity here.
There's a little too less and there's
a dial just on the law that Kirk,
can you just go and turn up and
people float a little bit easier?
Good question. I'm on space. Age does not
a good question. It was a good question.
Both me and Brian be like, wow,
what a good question. You're,
you're taking credit for something
that was not that good fellow.
Did you know Venus is a planet
that rotates clockwise? Holy Shit.
Check this dude out.
This guy has been up there for 748 days.
Ooh,
whoa. I bet he's crazy. Oh No. No
cumulative time in space ever. Oh,
okay.
You cons?
I think there's guys who can mean they
dropped him off at his space station,
left him up there.
There's a country. Yeah,
because isn't that what the space shuttle
does is go up and give those guys like
help them out and well, yeah, they
leave him up there for a few months.
That's gotta be so hard.
I mean,
I've been a gas stations in middle of
the country where dudes I think are
equally as trapped. Well they don't move
around much up there either. You know,
there's not like a lot of
room. It's not like, you know,
you're up in like a hotel
room in the sky. Like, no,
you're in like these fucking tubes.
What happens if you go counseling or you
can, you know, there's, there was one,
um, there was an issue where they were
talking about having a gun on board and
whether or not they should have
gun on a case. If the shoes,
I should look up that too.
Gun on speeding. Crazy.
Youtube commentators are just astronauts
that have gone crazy up in spaces being
assholes because they're
fucked.
His video space station
crew can access a gun. Yeah.
Yeah. They have a gun up there, man.
They have a gun up, Derek. He said what?
He goes low loony k.
Some dude goes like fucking event horizon
and pulses eyeballs out and starts
screaming Latin at you. Do you ever
see that movie dad? They went into,
they went through some fucking wormhole
and it's like some futuristic science
fiction horror movie and it's
what the dude from Jurassic Park,
I forget his name, but uh, it's kind of
fun. It's kind of stupid fun, you know,
stupid fun space, horror
movie. And he uh, he goes,
naughty guy with a gun.
Did you see that video of that cop debt?
This guy was Robin,
like a cvs cop comes in
just to get something into
standing behind them and then
realizes what he's doing. If you, you
know, I think it's new. No. Where's that?
Is that a great deal? Here's the deal
with the gun. The Russians have the gun,
those mother fuckers every, this is
how it goes on the spaces. Every space.
Craft carriers, survival gear for crash
landing and the Russian suse, s, O, y,
u, Z. I don't know how to say that.
Suis Suez has a kit that includes a gun.
Russians leave it to the Russians.
There's smart man. They're like, well,
I fuck around building a gun. We have a
gun than a kettle bell. You don't need it.
You have it better done than to need it
and not have the gun has been there for
as long as the space
station has been an orbit.
Its existence has been kept secret.
NASA and Russian officials
won't talk publicly about it.
That's funny.
You can't talk about the fact that people
might go crazy because then you plant
that little seed out there and
then they could possibly go crazy.
It's very tricky, right? Hmm. No,
that's not, you know, you gotta
be tricky, man. You don't want to,
you want to plant the seed.
You want to say everyone who's done
this mission has found it invigorating.
They come back and you write a book.
It's foster phobia.
We're really gone by the first couple
of the preframe them before yourself.
All the view is so spectacular.
I guarantee you,
you're just going to have a
smile on your face all day.
Don't forget to take pictures.
You think you're there and then there
you are on day two and you're like,
oh my God, I'm stuck up here
for six months. Gun. What?
The God closet in the cloud and he's a
Chinese guy. Keeps filling with a gun.
I want to kill him with these chopsticks.
Shut off.
I get about the gun fucking ears.
There's a gun on this.
Make sure that bullet
only goes through him. No,
and not through the Hall Mall Space.
How do you shoot a gun and space?
What if you blow a hole through the
wall? Doesn't everything explode? I mean,
aren't you going like fucking 3000 miles
an hour or something crazy and what?
I think when you're on an airplane can,
if you should have gotten in an airplane,
yes. You know what else tries me crazy
about the space station. My seat up.
There I go.
Wouldn't you think constantly that you're
going to get hit by a
meteor or an asteroid?
I guess there's a lot of stuff up there,
dude. I would be fucking freaking figure.
I mean if they figured
out how to avoid it,
I don't think there's been an
instance where anybody's gotten hurt.
But if you look at the night
and you see like shooting stars,
those are fucking just rocks
not manned by that stuff.
They have one guy just on thruster,
just like a video game.
We're going to head comm. They don't
see those things until they're awake.
It's till it's way too late.
And the darkness of space,
you don't see things like you. You
can't just look out for it, you know?
And little ones,
micro meteors,
they're like little fucking grains of
sand that will go right through metal.
You know though, how do you
not get it? But I don't know.
I don't know how they avoid that.
Somehow or another,
maybe they just roll the dice and
hope everything's going to be okay.
But if they got caught in some sort of
media I'd shower and it just hit the
right spot. Like, Oh man, I think
could get fucked up. Hmm. And,
and you don't have like force fields,
no force fields.
So that's not the idea of us getting
wiped out by a meteor. Seems so alien.
Seems impossible.
It seems so stupid.
Like to even bring it up is like you
think you really worry that people would
get wiped out by a meteor impact
or an asteroid impact really.
Does that really bother you that much?
But then you know that it's happened like
all these times throughout the history
of the earth. Like why wouldn't
we be thinking about that?
Why the fuck did we think that we're
immune to all the shit that has definitely
happened before. Right. You know,
we just keep going through like,
hey we're going to be fine. No
worry bumped meteors. Come on man.
In one sense it's true. You can't
live your life worrying about meteors.
Cause then you waste your whole life
and you're an old man on your death bed
going, fuck not a single media. And
then you'd die and then yet you know,
and you go, God, I could've had a goddamn
party if I just ignore those meteors.
But that's like with everything into
one that focuses their time on that is
ridiculous.
Like,
did you see that story of that lady was
just driving with her whole family and
like a car in front of her,
like hit up pot,
a pot hole that they fixed,
but they didn't fix it all the way.
And so when the car in
front of it hits it,
it made the concrete fly off and it went
right through the windshield of the car
behind them and just woman's face
smashed, gone. And she died instantly.
And it's like, that's like a meteor. You
know? If you're worrying about a meteor,
same thing would've happened.
You'd just be dead, you know?
Why would you be so concerned about
meteors killing you? You know,
when anything be
some strong logic there. Brian, you know,
I liked the way you said that. Oh yeah.
I mean,
I'm not really worried about meteor,
so I don't think anybody would be or
could be. Right. You can't really,
you can't even intellectualize it.
That's what I'm saying.
It's like the idea is so alien to us.
It seems like it's fiction.
It seems ridiculous, even though
it's absolutely true. Yeah.
We'll probably be hit by Mexico
before we be hit by a meteor.
I think the aliens are coming first before
anything happens to come in and save
us. John F John F on, do
you believe in aliens? Um,
I would say yes. There's
got to be, we can't.
I think we can't be the only
once we would most likely.
But do you think they've ever been
here? Um, I would like to think so.
I don't know. I mean, you watch all the,
the pyramid stuff and then you see people
try to create and you can go, okay,
how was that? Or yeah, but
that doesn't mean that the,
the most likely scenario for
the pyramids is not that if you,
if you go and do it, the most likely
scenario, which is really fascinating,
is that they were an incredibly,
incredibly advanced civilization.
And it's somehow or another,
they fell from that high level of
advancement and became, you know,
rather ordinary, which is how Egypt
is now. You know, that's what's I,
I'd say actually even more fascinating
that it was obtained by human beings and
that something happened. Whether it's,
you know, people just kept coming in.
My joke that I still,
my act is that all these dumb people out
fuck the smart people and there was no
smart people left and they wonder what
their version of keeping up with the
Kardashians was.
Cause maybe something like that happened
and then should they were going to be
this super smart race. Then Bam. Dot.
Hasselhoff you blaming the
keeping up with the Kardashians,
those type of shows that still
shows are just a symptom.
There are a symptom of the rot under the,
what was their version of that like?
Maybe there was a guy who stood in front
of a colleague seeing things and people
listened to him and then they stop.
I think most likely the
Egyptians were super advanced,
but there were advanced in a completely
different direction than we're advanced.
You know,
we've spent all this time and you know,
working on computers and working on
technology and working on, you know,
the ability to split the atom and
nuclear power and all this crazy shit.
Whereas I think they spent a lot of their,
their science and their ideas on studying
the cosmos and they had all these
wacky ideas about the afterlife and
the human body and that they're there.
They were fascinating
as far as like their,
their ability to make objects and
construct things that were so much more
advanced than anybody else near them.
Anybody else,
anywhere else in the world of fun?
I mean they were making these incredible,
incredible fucking structures,
like the Great Pyramid, 2 million,
300,000 stones.
I mean some people think they poured
them with concrete and they made concrete
out of them. Some people think they
were caught, whatever the fuck they did.
I mean the fact that anybody was able
to do that at least a few thousand years
ago where they think it's 2,500 BC.
But there's some other people like John
Anthony West that think that, you know,
the, the, the oldest part of
Egypt is even older than that,
but there's some structures that they
found under the sand that predate even the
construction of the Great Pyramids
that are these amazing, you know,
stone structures.
And the idea is that there was a,
a civilization there thousands and
thousands and thousands of years ago,
maybe even 30,000 years,
a really super advanced civilization.
And that there was a few of these all
over the world, but some shit happened,
some shit went down, whether it's
a meteor or whether it's, you know,
some crazy supervolcano or some massive
fucking disease that killed everybody.
Hmm. The weird thing is
you're from Detroit, right?
The weird thing is when
civilizations fall apart,
it does not take long for the
fucking earth to take back
the land. Yeah. You know,
Detroit,
I mean has a huge issue now with first
of all bears and some of the outlying
cities,
the outlying towns,
bears have started moving into towns
because there's so few houses because the
houses are broken down
and all these houses,
there's like a website
that was dedicated to it.
All these houses where trees are growing
through the fucking the front floor and
the porch is getting eaten up by trees.
It's like nature is just taken over
that shit over in a couple of decades.
Not even.
Yeah,
and that's the thing about Detroit.
It's not even a scary city in the sense
that there's a lot of people there.
It's so ghost towny yeah,
you can go for subdivision cause they
were trying to do a lot of that urban
farming where they were just going to
blow up subdivisions and stop putting
greenhouses and going, let's just start
growing stuff in the middle of the city.
Wow. They're really going to
turn it back into the country.
That's what they're doing.
How nutty is that urban?
There's so few people there that that's
like actually a legit move. Yeah. Yeah.
There's tear down the houses and build
huge greenhouses and just dealt right now
cause now that can do that with
soil and they can just all right.
That's why if the, you know,
well we were the last pot,
well we were there for the well that
would definitely help them. You know,
just call on when we were there for the
UFC they said it's 33% unemployment rate
in Detroit now. 33% that's
insane. Yup. One out of five.
That's insane. It shows you what those
auto jobs through what one auto job did,
you know that's amazing.
One out of three is unemployed three guys.
One of them was out of work. That's
amazing. And when you go there it's,
it's such a weird vibe that it obviously
so that everybody has that mentality.
Everybody just feels like all my,
you know,
my whole family and everyone I went to
high school with and college all has that
we've been beat on mentality like do but
til way better off than third
world countries. You know,
if everybody just moved
in together and you know,
and had less meaningful if w
two out of three are working,
that's still way better than Guatemala.
You know,
if everybody had like a real sense of
community and hoard it all together and
got all the family together and they all
ate meals together and they all shared
wealth. Yeah. You know,
it's just, it would be fine.
There's still a first world country.
It's still America,
but nobody wants to live like that and
everybody wants to have their own fucking
parking spot. And you know, I mean,
in one sense, I understand. I mean,
everybody used to have it just a
little while ago, but in other sense,
no matter how bad Detroit is, you
know, it's not fucking Peru. No.
You know what I mean?
There's some spots in this,
there's some spots in this
country or this, uh, this
map rather, where, you know,
you can go to countries where there,
there's just fucked man.
They're never going to get out of
this hole. There's just poverty.
And everywhere you go, there's, you know,
these factories that are popping up out
of nowhere and they're polluting the
rivers and there's no jobs and
there's no fucking future and no hope,
just sadness. So Detroit not
that fucking bad, you know?
And I always slept around Goddamn time.
Still America.
Yeah. Yeah. I went to this bar
the other day called bar sinister.
Have you ever been to it Joe?
It's a bondage bar I've ever
been to bondage Barbara for
doing when you're not with me, I'm going
to lose you. But there were, there was,
there was, there was a party, you're
going to get raped. I know those places.
There was a, there was a party
though and it was pretty sweet.
But you walk in and there's like
these like handcuffs and just people,
normal growth. Like, oh my
god, ha ha, I'm at this bar.
They get tied up in these guys with whips
come out and just start spanking them.
They're just like, oh my God. Yeah.
You know, there were two normal girls.
Guess what? Those aren't
normal girls. Yeah. Well,
I mean normal girls don't
like full of whipple.
They looked like fucking snow white.
These girls are like, they were just like,
oh my God, we're out of at, you know,
like tourists. That's what they look like.
Okay. And it was the greatest
thing ever, man. He's like,
do you think they got caught up in the
moment or do you think that's like holy
loving it and it was just chicks?
It was kind of like the,
the crowd that you would see like
at dimples when you do Karaoke,
which is just a bunch of girls there
at the Party and have fun. It was like,
that is kind of bowls demos as a
thing that John used to be a dumb,
the master. He would go every
weekend when he was, uh,
it was by my house in Burbank. It just,
uh, you see it on a lot of TV shows.
It's like the first karaoke bar
in the country and it's, I mean,
that's her Brittany Spears got busted
for if we're doing like a lot of famous
people go there. It's the dive.
Iest uh, that's where they were at.
The Bar story happened and uh,
yeah,
but I used to live right dash
paint Christmas eve there.
Once I spent Christmas,
there was no dancing by yourself.
He rocked George.
Michael was your thing, right? Yeah.
Yeah. We me and a buddy would sing.
What song would you sing last Christmas?
Well he would sing cause he's from
wherever. George Michael's farm.
So he sounds exactly like them.
George Michael.
So I would just be up there and the people
that are like, you guys are so good.
Keep in mind, dude, I was 24 years
old when I see a little George. Mike,
you were the guy you were
trying hard to karaoke. No,
karaoke scares me to death.
I literally will have a panic attack
before I get on stage and sing.
Unless there's like five
other people with me,
then I can just be the guy
who gets lost in the back.
So what are you talking about then?
But I would go on stage. Right.
And then, you know, cause I'm
still, and then you'd sing a song.
It was either this one or in the funny
thing, you would do this in July.
Took it song, sing it for us,
John. No, I think that's a really,
really like, if this comes on the
radio, are you going to change it? Um,
to be honest,
I would probably leave it on,
I wouldn't have to go from m
and M to this to seven dust. Uh,
I would have to be really, really
hard to listen to this. Yeah,
really high.
I would have to be so hard that I
shouldn't be driving or there was no other
cars around you while you were driving.
I have gotten so high,
those by myself at an airport cuddled
up in the corner with the iPod going,
what is this going on here?
That's what the song is. The song,
you renew the lot cards in Los Angeles.
The guy plays his song and goes, Julie,
you like this? And then if you go, yeah,
I'm kind of into it. Here's your card.
This is, this is one of those songs you
find in your iPod and you really go,
what the fuck was going on?
How about you're at the gym and
somebody asks you a question,
when you take it out of your ears,
this is what they here. Do you ever um,
press shuffle and get embarrassed
by your collection of Shit?
Yeah. That you have? Yeah, I have some,
I have some songs that I'm not sure if
I bought them as a goof or you're in the
mood sometimes I just don't know.
You know,
how many times have we been on the road
and we'd go to like a record store and
you'd just buy the most ridiculous cds
just cause you and Joey Diaz started
talking about in the car.
And next thing you know you have mc
hammer the ghostbuster too soon. Yeah,
track. Hey, track four is legit.
My Proton pack on my back and disparate
Joey Diaz will get me excited about
music. That's the truth. Joey Diaz
starts talking about pink Floyd.
Do you want to move to England? Where
were they? What's the neighborhood?
What's the street like?
I drive in the left hand side.
I'm fucking moving man money and we're
just going to sit and listen to it all
day. Let me Cox like a David Gilmore
in 1972 dirty white boys in England.
These dirty motherfuckers coming up with
the greatest music the world has ever
known. The world has ever known. Dog,
I'll give you the fucking address.
1826 Lancaster street. You're like, I
gotta get on a plane. I'll kind of go,
I've got to find my destiny.
The craziest thing with Joey when he
talks about music is sometimes he'll just
break out somebody's name and I'd be like,
no way. That's a good song. He's like,
no,
it's John Test and the pointer sisters,
they're doing it too wet and you're like,
no way is that good.
And he puts it on and it's great. Oh,
he's kind of a knowledge for it. Well,
all he does is smoke weed and sit around
and come up with shit. Yeah. You know?
I mean, that's what he does. He smokes
weed. He watches Clint Eastwood movies.
He smokes weed. He watches Steve
McQueen movies. He smokes weed.
He listens to music, he smokes
weed. He writes jokes. Have
you seen black swan yet?
What does that,
it's a new horror movie.
Or a suspense movie called Black
Swan and everyone that has seen it,
it's told me that is the craziest movie
of the year. You've got to see it insane.
It's, you haven't heard about
it? No, I haven't heard anything.
It's called Black Swan I think is
black swan. Let me double check,
but I'm pretty sure it's black. So on.
Wow. Um, whenever they heard hazing, man,
I don't know man. It,
yeah, it's Black Swan.
Yeah.
Here, check out this
trailer, uh, of this movie.
Yeah.
This is pretty crazy.
And it's a Free Camille Black Swan.
Is this an American film?
Yeah.
We're going to play with them.
The video later, gentleman.
[inaudible] you can't see it.
It's a green band trailer.
Okay.
It's restricted.
Had the craziest dream last night.
Better girl who's turned into a smile
pair prints cause for the wrong girl.
She kills her stuff.
[inaudible]
he burned Mr. Feature me more
this season. Oh, he should.
You've been there long enough and you're
the most dedicated dancer in the company
or New Swan Queen.
The exquisite Nina Sears.
Lilly, you're going to be amazing
how much? The way she moves central.
She's not faking it.
These are all hot jacket.
Come on.
They go in through ballet. I
took a class here. You sweet.
Kurt's about to get crazy on my dodge
was hard for teachers.
I don't want to talk about that. Feeling
me to relax. [inaudible] it's the rule,
isn't it? It's all this pressure.
I knew it'd be too much. I knew it.
What's she doing here?
He made me your ultimate,
the only person standing
in your way is you.
[inaudible] Hey,
no wireless.
I have my ways.
Whoa. Lesbos Shit. Yeah. Oh, they're
going at it. I thought it was a hard movie
to my sweet girl.
Be sure this is the hardware we did. Yeah,
I heard it's really fucked up too. Yeah.
Yeah.
I think that the rotten tomatoes score
is like 83% they're not going to show you
any monsters. Look her eyes. Whoa.
What's going on there? I don't know.
She's turning into a swan. Really?
When's this come out? It's out right now,
but yeah, it's been long period has been
going through tonight. Let me go tonight.
Uh, I can't, I got to stand
up. Comedy did too. Oh,
really? Yeah. It's
house south, by the way.
Sunday I'm having a little
comedy show at Sal's.
It's going to open mic mixed
with comics. Like, like, like,
like regular commingle comics. Yeah.
It's gonna be a lottery systems though.
It might come down. Yeah.
Check Salads. Feeling better.
New Soles on Melrose Avenue,
Melrose. And what a, it says Vienna cafe.
It's a yellow awning or right
across the street from us. Seven 11.
I don't know the cross street
off hand, but it's on Melrose.
Yeah, it's on Melrose,
east or west of, um, the uh, improv.
If you're a northeast, it's south of
the Improv. Isn't that right? South? No,
because they're on the same street and
the street goes east to west. Okay.
If you're facing the Improv, yeah. Turn
left and you go down to me. That's east.
East. Yeah, I think, yeah.
Yeah. The ugly. Right.
88% for black swan on rotten
tomatoes. Him. That's pretty strong.
It's out right now outright. It's that
cool. I heard it was fucking Badass low.
I saw heard that fighter movie was really
good. That's really good too. Yeah,
that's the one I want to Christian
Bale, man, that guy, there's,
there's dudes who like,
they do something when they get a role,
you know,
that completely transforms their body but
nobody does it. Like that fucking guy.
Did you ever see the machinist?
Yeah.
How did those guys change their bodies
so much? What did you see? The machinist,
you know he did no,
do you know what I'm talking about?
Full blown.
And machinists was a movie
where he lost super skinny.
He was eating like an apple and
a can of tuna a day. That's it.
And he literally like, he probably
fucked up his body. Like when you're,
when you do something like that and
you probably take years off your life,
you probably damage your organs.
Like what he did was extreme like
really like almost like he looked like a
monster, you know, like he would, he
would like make life a little crazy,
like you know, gestures and there's
photos and videos of it all on online.
Like people use it as a
avatars on message boards.
Just because it's so fucking
creepy, man. There's,
there's dudes that are willing to go
that extra mile and he's one of them.
And then how do they get
big enough to be Batman?
Just get on the juice son here.
Start telling some spots,
eat some burgers. I don't know. I
mean I guess if you, you rehydrate,
um,
I guess like how long would it take
you to get back to your normal salvo?
Take months.
It would definitely take notes months
and months and you would have to do it
slowly. You know, your body just
suddenly you starve it like that.
Your body like would not be very receptive
to weight lifting or anything either.
You're Bobby probably be so freaked out,
you know,
just probably trying to like
try not to. Yeah, yeah. No Shit.
All then I won't do it then. Don't
do that, dude. What'd you do that,
if you ever got a movie,
Somebody said, John have fun.
We want you to be in this movie,
but you've got to play this crack head.
You got to lose like 100 pounds.
You got to look all fucked up when
a scratch you up and my whole life,
ever since I wrestled 98 pounds than
one oh five I just kept telling myself,
I will rule the world if I'm one
60 I haven't ruled the world.
If I'm one 70 now I'm
like one 80 I'm like,
I need to get back to one
70 my face is round and fat.
Too many singers losing weight
in high school for wrestling.
I did it for wrestling and
I did it for taekwondo.
It's the stupidest thing in high school.
Half the people that are
growing and they're, they're,
they're getting them to do stuff to
their body and cut weight so bad.
Luckily I was always little
so I never had to cut.
I mean I was that small anyway. Yeah,
but you didn't cut anything? I never did.
Oh really? Yeah, I know. I've always
had us cut everybody cut weight.
I was always like four pounds under
whatever way class, so I never was like,
I'm going down.
My friend Anthony used to lose an insane
amount every year and he always talks
about how he,
he would just eat everybody's Italian,
his whole family beat and Pasta and he'd
be sitting there with a cup of shaved
ice and that's what he was
allowed to eat and they'll just,
cause he had to drop all this weight and
even nutrition and how to do that stuff
has changed over the last 10 20 years. So
even fuck, even when we were in school.
Oh yeah,
the UFC guys have it down to a science.
Then you go and still eat a lot and get
strong and add muscle and still lose
weight. It's crazy. You'd like
to use American top team guys.
I've never seen anything like it.
These guys, somehow or another,
I don't know what they do, they just
have it down to like an art form.
They know how to get these guys there.
They get them to cut like 20 pounds over
the course of a few days and you know,
and it's not that long. It's a, it's a
pretty short amount of time they do it in.
And then the guys weigh in and then
they balloon him back up and they,
they gained like 15
pounds, 20 pounds. Yeah.
We walked in once on Tiago Elvis,
he was a in the gym at the palms and it
was a day he was fighting and they had
him the day of the fight, they
hadn't gone through all these, uh,
shadow boxing moves, like
go, go, go, go, go, go.
It was burning like he's trying
to like put all this, you know,
glycogen depletion out of his muscles.
And then he would give him some sort
of a drink and the drink was like this
carbohydrate drank that refueled all the
muscles so the muscles got back to full
size.
So that was the idea is that you make
them work and then when you make them work
a little bit, it allows them to
take in more moisture, more water,
and they get thicker. More
sugar. Yeah. These guys,
they haven't down to an art form.
And so they have these guys like yours,
you know, and t Bowers, he's the
biggest 155 pound fighter on the planet.
He's one of those guys where
you looking at me and go,
how the fuck is that guy won 55 well,
he's not,
he's only one 55 for like an hour or
I know he's won 55 he gets down to the
weight,
it weighs in and then they give them a
little pedialyte and then they give them
bags of Ivy. Like most guys use ivs now.
You know, that's the smart way to do it.
To get water back in your system.
They need to have I ve places for people
who leave bars that are like really
boozed up. We can just plug
in and feel good. Yeah.
But it's good man. It's that
simple. You're fucked. You know,
it's kind of go through your whole system,
you know?
There's no shortcut to sobering up. I
don't think they can do that with an ivy.
But yeah, if they could, that would
be the [inaudible] or the next day.
How about that? When, when you know,
when you feel super super
that well you could do that.
You could go the nearest banana bag or
something, popping in like a Jiffy Lube.
Sit there for 15 minutes.
Get plugged in.
If you went to a place you know that
could rehydrate you with like a vitamin
drip in and ivy and you know the Sugar
Water Iva, you could totally do that.
We should do it. You know why? Why not?
Why not do that man plugin sit there
like a hangover stations in Vegas.
Oh, that'd be perfect. No, but the problem
is people don't want to get needles. Man.
You'll go into stick some fucking
needle in my arm. Whoa. I'm fine man.
I'll just drink some water. Depends on
how screwed up he got the night before.
But isn't that the, the main thing with
um, with hangovers, isn't it dehydration?
Isn't that what's really fucking you
up? Yeah, it's, you're just, yeah,
your body's depleted from all that
stuff. So put it back in. Powerful.
That's why at the end of the night,
I usually switch to beer and water for
like the last couple of years and then
after that,
that's really smart.
You should pound pound water when you
get home to just force yourself to drink
way more than you want to just
pound it, pound it. Yeah. You know,
speaking of Vegas,
picking up pounded at February for me,
Joe Diaz and Ari Shaffir at
the Mandalay Bay theater.
It's the day before the Superbowl
weekend UFC to be a sick UFC to Anderson
Silva's fighting Vito Belfort.
And uh,
that's going to be off the chain
and I'm sure there's a great
supporting cast as well. I don't
know the full card yet, you know,
it's kind of when they're in
February. I was thinking like, man,
anything can happen between
now and February, you know,
in the MMA guys get
injured so often. US, Vma,
I've heard your voice almost every night
this week for three hours. Oh yeah.
You've been getting into the
UFC lately. I just, you know,
I just got a 2010 all the
game game flight it and it,
it came get that. So then that
got on the new one though. Yeah,
I was supposed to work this week,
but I can't because my voice
and then I created John Heparin,
a hundred and hundred 80 pounder. Look at
you. I thought you want to be one seven.
It's easy to learn.
I heard it's really hard.
I heard that the controls
are pretty hard to master.
I buttoned smashed for awhile now.
I've got one or two moves,
but I swear playing the video game,
but I think it's all how you visualize
stuff that you actually learn.
You can learn some ground stuff
by doing it on the video game.
100% really like actual moves.
Oh,
here's somebody put on the message board.
Somebody puts some
photos of Christian Bale.
Look at those pictures will
be the one on the left.
Dude. God Damn, he's crazy. I
did it again for this movie too.
He got super skinny for this
movie to hmm to play crack. Ed.
Why don't you just get like a cool one
when you can eat a lot and just become a
fat slob? Well, that's fine. That
role. That's what a dinero used to do,
or even a Matt Damon did it. Denny Denny
for his last one where it's like a,
he's a CIA agent, but maybe it's kind
of supposed to be funny. Not Serious.
We gained really? Yeah, and you
just ate a lot of pasta and donuts.
A just got written the outage that is
that the movie about the dude who's like
some swings in informant, the informant.
That was obviously a good mood. Yeah,
I didn't see it. Yes, I didn't. Why
didn't I have to gain weight for that?
I think he did though because these
guys wanted to be doe. Yeah. Yep.
That's absolutely fine. Yeah.
Stallone did that once too.
Remember that he did that for cop land.
He gained a gut and there was like, Whoa,
so fast. Yeah, that was a good maybe,
but I think that UFC going through some
of the ground stuff than in your brain,
you kind of learn. Okay.
I think that's how you, do
you think you've actually
applied something that you
learned from the game to a
sparring session? Have you done that?
I think you would have, you know? No,
but I think people do all the time.
What are fights like in school now,
do you think? How many kids
you got to MMA? You know,
I'm like fighting it so much more of a
part of our culture now that it was just
a couple of decades ago.
Even let's even go 10 years ago.
Do you think anybody in let's
say just a regular, you know,
nonlethal just fight with everything
about throwing your knee. Nobody would.
Nobody was,
everybody was headhunter.
But now I've seen youtube fights where
guys clinch and throw on that strictly
from watching UFC. Oh yeah. Directly
from just, just seeing it going,
all of that exists. Let me bring
that into my repertoire. Yeah. Yeah.
It seems like a move that
anybody can do to, you know,
it doesn't, it's not like a
giant flying head kick, you know?
It seems pretty simple.
I even grabbed the guy and you throw
your knee up and you hit him. You know,
it's not like they're complicated. Yeah.
Or, and you were to get ahold of them,
or even dirty are clenching or dirty
by holding that and stuff like that.
A lot of that's going and watching
youtube fight with this guy.
Have you seen the break one? When the
guy just says, put me out. It's this kid,
he's got really baggy pants. He's just
telling this guy, let's go, let's go.
He says, put me out. He
go, yeah, put me down.
He's like telling the guy to knock
them out, but his hands are, are at,
is this the guy? Knock them out. It's
an awesome really to really skinny kids.
And then there he almost like there's
a type equipment. Is it a fight? No.
They're on the street. One guy staying
or is it a fight? No, it's, it's a fight.
Okay. In one guy's got like a phone,
which I have, but it, I took it off here.
I have a video.
When I was in grand rapids,
this guy was trying to fight.
He fought a couple guy.
This guy has like a sweater on,
puts his hand in his pocket
and starts walking over to him,
grabs him right,
spins around,
throws in a rear naked
choke when he's on top.
So this guy obviously knows some type of
fighting because he was way too cocky.
You don't put, you know, so he's
got a rear naked choke on the guy,
jumps up in the air in and knocks
out the guy's legs so you know,
wants to fall down with him. But
he's got his back, he's standing,
the guy now who had the rear naked
choke and falls to the ground because he
pulls the guy on top of them,
smashes his head onto the cement cause
you're in the middle of the street.
Oh Shit.
Now loses a thing.
Pretty much is knocked unconscious and
that guy rolls on top of them and just
starts wailing them.
And I had it on my phone up
until I was in the middle.
Then a huge fight broke out and then I
decided to put my phone away. I'm like,
why would that guy think to pull guard?
You know what I mean?
Cause that's also from watching
kind of UFC where you go,
you know that I would have just stayed
standing and wouldn't choke the guy out
from standing. He's just fucked
up. Yeah. Yeah. It was like,
it was the craziest thing I've ever
seen. I'm like wow, that guy just,
he did a duck under,
you know,
so he goes to grab ducks under then
throws in the choke and the guy then jumps
up and pulls the guy right on top of,
there's so many street fights.
No on fuck fucking cell phone cameras.
I love watching them.
I just like watching them to see
what, what guys do in, in, in there.
But the other one I saw this guy throws
a knee and then the guy black block the
knee, you know, put, Kinda
did that little handout thing,
but you know, they didn't notify
you. Jump from the iTunes listener.
John was just moving his hands left and
right. What, cause he was like saying, uh,
uh, he was taking his knee over here
for the iTunes. There's been, I'm,
I'm trying as I have enrolled
or done anything in forever,
but there was this guy on youtube
that showed a, um, a thing,
so he's on his back, reaches
up, grabs the guys a head
and arm, you know, and pulls him close
and then sweeps him. Right? I'm like, oh,
that seems like a pretty cool
sweep to know with basic,
I don't know how practical it is
when you basically just reach up,
grab the guy's head, pull them in and
then plan a foot and then saw good.
As long as he doesn't
know what he's doing.
But I bet you spend running that
in my head over and over again.
This is what you get in.
Then I need to do at this class,
go to a Goddamn Jujitsu class. This is
what Kung people, Kung Fu people do.
They sit down and they go,
well, it's like grabbed,
you'd like this and then
I got your arm right.
He ain't not throw you on the ground.
And then they'll like practice
doing that over and over again.
Well that that's not how you do it.
The way you do it is you've got
to try it on somebody. I remember,
if you don't try it on somebody,
you've got some nonsense move that you
don't really know what's going to happen
if it got defense. Cause you have to
learn whatever. The guy grabs me here, oh,
if he grabs me here, I'm fucked. Okay.
So I have to stop them from grabbing me
here and then I have to make sure that
this leg gives and get past this lie.
Cause if it does, then I'm fucked again.
I remember when we did that a tour
together a couple of years ago,
the Tate was with us in some guy and
some guy was saying, yeah, I just,
you just do this and you break the guy's
leg and Tate just goes off and goes,
really? How do you know? Do
you have a room full of us,
small Chinese boys that you
break their legs and practice?
You've never broken a leg that way.
Have you ever seen anybody who's Bro,
it was funny. How do you know? How do
you know that, that you don't know. So,
so don't say it's going to bring some
really good impression that taste really
good. That's like the best impression
that Taylor I've ever heard.
It's totally true. Tate and I were, uh,
I think I've told this story before,
but I'll tell it anyway.
Tate and I were in a hotel in
Vegas and some big Douche bag.
Let's go. It was really a taint. It's
huge. Right? Tate is like six foot three.
He walks around like two 35 and
he's got a shaved head. He's coming.
He just looked. Yeah. You just see, look
at him and he'd go, no, probably not.
The guy in the room. I'm like,
yeah, it looks like a killer. Right?
And he's a nice guy,
but you know,
but people will fuck with him even
though he's this big, it's so ridiculous.
It's fucking kid who's like a frat boy.
He looked like he was about six foot six
and handsome fella drunk off his ass.
But he was being a really, really
aggressive and uh, you know, he's telling,
stated that wasn't his room tape
was like looking for his keys.
Like that's my room bro, while you
go to my room. And Tate was like,
looking at this guy, I was like,
no, I'm pretty sure it's my room.
And he sticks the key and they're like,
Tay was being really friendly about
it and the key works. He goes up,
seats my room. So he goes in,
take it easy and shuts the door.
And once he gets inside my
room was right next to him.
I hear Bang, Bang, Bang. I hear
pounding on his door, right? So,
uh,
we,
we go out into the hallway and the guy
is pounding on his door and the guys like
fucking pussy fucking
shut that door in my face.
I told you that's my fucking room. It
was like craziness. It was like, oh no,
what is going to happen here? And
tape was like, oh yeah, yeah. Big Guy.
Is that what's going on? This is your
fucking room, Huh? And the guy's like,
what do you fuck up?
Kick your fucking ass bitch.
She was saying all this crazy shit.
So Tate says, come on man, come on,
take a swing at me.
And the guy like doesn't know what to do,
doesn't know where to go.
And so he moved.
There was a lot of John back in
play before all this happens,
but I'm going to cut to the chase.
The chase was the guy steps forward.
Tate leg kicks him and then
pulls guard on the dude.
So he's got this guy on top of them in
in the lobby and he's got them in what's
called an Omoplata, which just got
him in the shoulder lock position.
And right when he gets him down,
he's got them in its own path to the
security guy. Show up, stop. Hey, stop,
stop the fight. Are you the guy
from fear factor? I go, yeah, yeah,
don't worry about this. This
guy's not going to get hurt. I go,
he's going to be fine.
He's just going to get choked unconscious.
This guy's an asshole. So then
Tate hears that. He goes, well,
I guess I'm choking on my conscious.
So Tate sinks or rear naked,
choke on them and puts them
totally asleep, doesn't hit him,
doesn't hurt him that God
doesn't have a scratch on him.
The guy's face down in the carpet,
unconscious snoring,
his friends come grab him,
apologize, pick the guy up,
put the guy in an elevator,
the elevator door closes and he
goes out of our life forever.
He just had odd by the
way, thank God. Yeah,
well he was just so embarrassed and he
probably didn't even know what the fuck
happened. The guy was so drunk
and so stupid. This is my room.
They never did anything to him.
Tate. They did not hurt him.
He did not hurt him at all.
He just incapacitated him,
taught Tom a quick lesson and his friends
were so happy because his friends were
like regular size dudes discloses giant
guy and this guy was a giant Douche,
you know, the whole day. And he
probably had to deal with that. Nice.
Just everybody where ever he goes,
what the fuck you looking at bitch?
They just one of those guys and
so he fucked with the wrong dude.
I mean it's like Karma
just led him to take
call university.
You know what?
We need to make a little
shift on how you view life.
You need to see drop
you off at floor five.
You've been treating people like shit,
looking to throw something in your life
that's going to push you in a different
direction. Yeah. I became
a yoga teacher after that.
I really tried to find a center. You back
with the goggles? I liked the goggles.
It's a cool look. You know what I like
about goggles when you're, you know,
I always wondered like
I watched Al Pachino get
interviewed the other day and he
got interviewed and he kept his
sunglasses on the whole interview.
He was talking to Larry King. I'm like,
what kind of nonsense is that? Is it,
is it hot in the room or is
it Brighton Room or something?
Like why do you have sunglasses on?
And he was talking about, I was so shy.
He wears sunglasses because he can't
even look people in the eyes. Like,
is that it or do they like,
it's really easy to pretend that you're
living in a movie and that life is like
some crazy fucking thing that
you've created when you're
looking through goggles,
you know? Yeah. I like wearing
sunglasses all the time. Yeah.
I just didn't ever want him. I just, I
like my eyes be as relaxed as possible.
Nighttime indoors, nighttime indoors
so much. But Hey, a bonded by colors.
You wear them indoors.
Uh,
like if I'm at a restaurant and it's
during the day and it's like bright in the
restaurant, I'll wear it once
in awhile. I'll wear my son.
But if you're having a conversation with
somebody, you take them off. Right, right.
If they're wearing glasses too.
So you just go with it. Yeah,
I remember like I don't like,
I don't like squinting,
I hate squinting cause I squint on the
computer all the time. So I
like my, I like to massage
my eyes when I, when I can.
So it's not a matter of looking
cool. No, no, not at all. No.
It's relaxation of the eyes.
She,
she doesn't want your eyes
to have some shade on Him,
right? Hmm. Yeah. Interesting.
Yeah. Like I really like if
I'm at the olive garden, I
don't want to seed the, the,
the decor. I don't give a shit about
the paintings and stuff like that.
The power of Yardi.
Emily,
do you eat at Olive Garden family? Huh?
Do you eat at the, Oliver got eight there.
You got eat there bro. What's close and
you're hungry. It's not a bad choice.
Right? It's fast. The breadsticks
still good. I've been, it's great.
The only problem with the olive garden
is that lately there salads are half the
size it used to be. So
they'll still refill them all
you want, but they're like,
they take longer to get now
and they're half the size,
so they're trying to fill
you up so you get, you know,
full faster so you won't get them salads.
They're trying to get you full
bug giving you less salad. Yeah,
because they're there,
they're giving you half as much and so
you eat it and then you have to flag down
the, the weight, the weight or to get you
another one. That's a half one, you know.
So that's one full regular old school
salad that took twice as long to to go
through.
And the whole time you're sitting there
getting full use out of your sign of the
economy. Brian, they may
believe salad I believe soon.
So something that's troubling you.
So because it doesn't all
of garden fanatic, uh,
you could tell like nowadays all
olive garden fanatic. Fuck yeah,
I love the olive garden or you
like one of those Fandango dudes.
It's got like a little,
I'm actually,
I just don't care that much about the
f the off guard, but I go there a lot.
But you'll notice if you go to the
salad. Yeah, I do. I'm a Yelp elite.
But if you go to the salad,
uh, if you go to this,
if you look at the Saudis a lot smarter
now, how do you become a Yelp, Yelp elite?
You get chosen. What does Yelp, yeah.
And hopefully I just had to put in my
application to become the 2011 Yelp elite.
But hopefully they pass me. So if you're
listening yelpers, what does that mean,
Bro? What are you doing? Going to
a stadium and it's 12 guys, look,
I get this other badge that most people
don't have on Yelp. So just check it out.
Go to my profile and tell me what's
going on with Yelp. What do you yeah,
I don't even running around
reviewing things all day. No, no.
Once in awhile or review something.
Usually.
How many reviews do you have on
your account? Not, not that many.
I don't do it that much
anymore because I'm so busy,
but it's not their money here.
I'll tell you, hold on honey.
Yet big enough to get a Yelp elite. Yeah.
What does that mean, Bro? I think you're,
you're being very a sketchy
with my Yelp status.
A Yelp elite pretty much
only means that, uh, that,
that your reviews get pushed
up higher than the other guys.
I think B and modest burn and that a,
you get invited to Yelp parties,
which is a a great time.
Yelp parties have 95 reviews.
Wow.
That's a lot of reviews kid.
But I've been doing it since
2006 or 2007 or something. Damn.
You just go into whatever restaurant
store, just whatever it is and go. Yeah.
And the customer service,
we're okay. Yeah, exactly.
I do it for restaurant
member of the media.
Have you heard like
bloggers calling the media?
That's what it gets. Hilarious.
Right. You know, that was a member of,
as a member of the media,
like Whoa, what? Right.
But I guess they are right. I mean,
what the fuck is the difference?
I mean at a certain point in time we
have to make some sort of a distinction
because every douche bag that has a
website can't be in the team. You know,
there's some people that are
absolutely terrible at it.
Like you have to like if you were, uh,
uh, you know, a member of the media,
a writer for say, The New York
Times, you know, they had standards.
By the time he got to the New York Times,
you were a certain caliber of journalist,
you know,
but any asshole can just start a fucking
blog and basically now it's all the
same thing. You have just as much of a
possibility of getting your shit scene.
Yes,
some really high traffic thing.
If you write something good
and it's controversial or
totally interesting, one celebrity
tweets it, fuck, you know,
and then everyone goes
the there,
the media then then all of a sudden
they're showing up at places with cameras
and it's All v Webs fueled. You know,
it's how we live in a strange time, ma'am.
Look,
Joe,
I reviewed the hotel the day after the
fire at the hotel in San Francisco. Yeah,
the fire at the cliff and then one night,
that's a terrible hotel.
Stay at folks if you,
I mean if it's a nice hotel,
but if you're going to stay
there and a fire breaks out,
the fucking hotel has these staircases
that are these tiny single file
staircases.
They were jammed up with people.
You know what I heard when I was in
San Francisco, however many times ago,
I had dinner with, um,
Tim Ferriss, you know,
guy wrote four hour work week and
he just a four hour body and he was,
his buddy wrote this book called Emergency
Neil Strauss I think wrote emergency
just about how to live
like Bourne identity guy,
how to have a couple passports because
the problem is if stuff goes down and you
can't get out of your country,
that's all you know. So anyway,
he tells you to have extra passport.
This guy emergency says that's
a good way to get arrested, man.
Catch you with extra passports. How do
it, well, there's other countries, uh,
that will give you dual citizenship
real if you invest legal.
Yeah, yeah. Show you. But
you have to invest in their
infrastructure. So how much,
uh,
I think in the book the Guy was talking
to guy for like $100,000 or something.
Fuck Outta here.
[inaudible] up with $100,000.
Give us some whack ass little
fucking third world country.
You get to view a female.
Yeah. What are you doing, Bro?
You give an icon in Nigeria so then
you get fuck out of here Graham.
But he said the guy.
Nah, I could he, yeah.
He asked what hot many fire trucks you
think is there to protect the entire city
of San Francisco. And I was, I always
said, I don't know, probably hundreds.
It was I believe less than 20 total.
Whoa.
Now say these words, but I
could be wrong, but it's,
it's something like that where
you would think there's no,
there's hundreds for the entire city
of, no, there's literally big rigs
that can shoot water like 20 of them.
So if anything really happened in his
city like that, the thing is it's,
it's going to go well. We were the whole
show. The whole book is how to survive.
Like born,
we were at the hotel and the fire broke
out supposedly four 30 in the morning,
but it wasn't really a fire.
It was just some assholes that
blew off fire extinguishers.
But it looked like a fire
that it looked like a fire.
There was smoke because of
the extinguishers are like,
it looks like smoke and it's flooded,
you know, through the hallways.
And we were going down this little
single file staircase at four 30 in the
morning where people just shuffled
on the staircase. It was maddening.
Everyone was going so fucking slow.
It was really scary, man. It was.
I thought so hit their head and the
stairs going down and at one point like me
and Joe both felt like we're just going
to start beating up the people in front
of us. No more, no more hotels
that are from the 1700 now.
They didn't kiss my ass first floor,
second floor. Now I'm like first floor,
second floor. That's all I want. Well
it's just those old ass hotels man.
Like that's, that's your staircase,
right? I mean it was so small.
I literally had a hard time
getting through it. Me,
I have one person had a hard
time getting through it.
So I got skinny ass staircase and there
was fat people and old people and tired
people and people in poor health and they
were all just clogging up the stairs.
You know, you really, when you
see a person during the day,
you see a person that's all warmed up.
You know they've had coffee and they're
moving, you know what I'm saying?
They got up a couple of hours ago and
had breakfast and they're, you know,
walked out to the brisk,
you know,
cold air before they got into
the building where you meet them.
But when you see them,
boom,
right after they wake up and they're
all disoriented and their slowness might
get you burned to death. Yeah,
it's a fucking trip, man.
You always wonder about that when you're
on a plane or you have to sit in the
exit row and you're like, okay, I'll,
I'll open this if I have to wear these
hundred and 50 people active allies of
stuff. And then I always think,
no. I'm like, there's no way.
But then you hear about stuff like the
plane and landed in the Hudson where
everyone just orderly. You know, the
got 150 people out. I'm like, I dunno.
That's just such a,
that was a safety landing.
That landing was almost like they
landed on the ground. It was just,
they were on the water, you know,
it almost seemed like it made sense,
but I hear you. Yeah. Like you never
know what people just, you know,
climb over the week in the slow just
to save or is it already, I don't know.
I've never depends on the situation and
how dire the circumstances are and it
depends on, I mean, look at black
Friday or whatever it's called,
and you see people trampling over
each other to get into a store. Right.
So they're on a southwest flight. Chances
are you going to get trampled, right?
Yeah. So then you're good to go. Yeah.
If you're on virgin,
you're probably going to be okay.
Everyone's going to be cool with you.
Yeah. Have you flown many virgins? No,
I heard it's awesome though. Yeah. The
view. No, I haven't fun any of them.
John half on. You're a
world traveler, Huh? You're
constantly not around the world,
but I mean around the country
you're covering stand up. Yeah.
It's a lot of fucking lasts. I don't like
planes anymore, man. Last year, yeah,
last year was 40 something
weeks or something.
And then I have this week off and then
June 1st is my first week and the you in
and off starting next week. And I leave
God, you just out every weekend. Yeah.
How do you do that? It's a used
to be easier, but now I uh,
to be honest then now I occupy my time
with so much other little projects during
the day that that's what gives me, you
know, like dancing. I dance, I do my,
my ribbon thing. I'm in my a knife
fighting and Cain fighting class stars.
Do you take classes and shit when you go
on the road? Like if you go on the road,
are you a Wednesday through Sunday guy?
Like how do you do the road Wednesday?
Yeah, Wednesday through Sunday.
So you can't say travel day.
You're just home Monday,
Tuesday and then Bam,
you're out on the road on Wednesday?
Yeah. Sometimes a Thursday, you know,
leave on Thursday.
Is your wife meet you places?
Do you like try to set it up where you
see each other more than two days a week?
No. Whoa. I mean we used to, um, but
now she's got a job. So No, you know,
when we see each other like asking
classes, like when I was in Atlanta,
um,
there's a boxing gym by my hotel,
so I would go in there and then work
with that guy for a couple of days.
Just do you ever go to the boxing gym
and they try to set you up and once I'm
doing to spar with you, uh, I won't
do Mount Holyoke asked you though.
I had before and I've gotten beat up,
you know, then you're on stage going,
somebody beat you up, not beat
up. But you know, other guys,
60% might be different than my 60% and
it's a funnier story if some guy knows
who I am and knocked
me out then going 60%.
That's a boring story. Right. So, yeah,
it's hard to trust people. I don't, when
you're spoiling me, unless you find,
you know, do you have a problem with tr
Accra Krav Maga Class A couple times?
You know when you're sparring. And
I'm really, I pride myself in going,
if we're going to go 50, we're
going to go 50. I don't have an ego.
I don't need to go 65 and prove anything
to you were both here to learn and blah
blah blah, blah. But there is a couple
of times where I haven't been, I just,
I still get even mad thinking about
kicking 40 50% a five year old could
probably catch that.
Kik when you literally are just going
more of the Mo motion to maybe step in.
The guy catches my foot and
then straight just, you know,
just how hard you punched you in the first
enough.
Why all stars and fell to the ground.
Do you think you hit your hundred percent?
Uh, he pretty hard. Not, not
a hundred, but it was, no,
it's tricky, right? There was no
martial arts classes. A tricky,
you've got to make sure that the
people that you're training with,
you trust them. You know,
that's where, when you,
when you're striking things get weird
when you, you know, kicking him punching.
Yeah. Cause you know you really
can't do it full blast everyday.
So you've got to assume that the guy is
going to be willing to work with you and
you know, we're just going to kind of
tag each other. So we work on our timing.
Yeah. That's why I like doing like
just I go to a place like that,
I'll do a lot of just bag work or Mitt
work and bounce around where there's
really, except for the midst maybe
slapping yet, like that's equally as well.
I just want to do it to give me
something to do and get my heart rate up.
So I don't want you to take the guys
on the road with you. Uh, used to.
And then the last couple of months I
haven't cause evolved con Kinda cutting,
not famous, but then they kind
of move on and they're like,
I don't feel like witchy to me is,
you know, you gotta get slackers,
get people who just don't want
to get famous and yeah. Yeah.
Then I've got to go on the road on
the roads too hard yet. It's funny,
his kids I used to, now I think starting
next year I'm going to find some guys,
but I'm going to have some rules.
You know he, I know that sounds dumb,
but I did a show where it was me and
brewer is both of us pretty amazing show
cause I'm high, low level and he's
even even higher level. But I did,
I didn't do more in 20 minutes in
front of them in and then he would,
but during that 20 minutes I'm like wow,
that feature spot you will,
you don't have time for anything. There's
no time to talk to people in the crowd.
20 minutes. It's very quick. Yes.
So then now when I see guys opening for
me having conversations with the crowds,
I'm like,
how do you have the time stop that do
20 minutes of nonstop material and then
get off the stage. Don't have a, I
don't know how. So now I got, yeah,
but sometimes when you're opening though,
sometimes like talking to the crowd
just a little bit here and there,
it kind of like brings everybody to,
I'm talking, no, I'm talking feature.
I'm not talking to MC.
So just the feature,
that spot you should just go up
and rip. Just be yeah. You know,
I think,
but then I was fine.
Guys that sit on the stool
and these start day there,
everybody's got their own thing
though man. Like, but for me, uh,
you know in front of me, those
guys. So I gotta I gotta fine. Yeah,
I've got to find,
got to find the right God.
That's funny that you
monitor what they do.
Why don't monitor and say anything but it,
but it bothers you when
they sit on the stool.
But that's 40 some weeks a year and
that's where that kicks in where then now
you just find little things, a bitch
book. It's funny where you go to a Condo,
the same guy, you go with the
same guy 40 weeks in a row. Um,
I used to settle, drive you crazy. Yeah,
I think that's what I got to do is fine.
You start telling them what to do with
his act. Like don't sit on a stool.
Don't ever say anything. No, I don't see
any bigger roles. You say you got rules?
Well now if I have a
new guy opening for me,
I would kind of find a guy and you go,
okay, I let his yet. I like his style.
So you treat it as if he's an employee.
The only thing I don't like
dude's doing is what's the tricky.
It gets tricky if you,
you bring a guy with you
and then he starts talking
about the shit that you talk
about before you talk about it.
Then you're like, hey man, you know,
I already talk about that.
Like,
why are you talking about that when you
bring me up? And I thought, that's weird,
you know? Yeah. You know, it's funny,
as you're walking to work with guys,
let's say that are just
there and as the week goes,
I notice this and they'll start
doing more and more. Yeah, similar,
lightly touching, not even doing it, but
just dusting in enough where you're like,
really? You haven't watched what I've
done who do that on purpose? You know?
They do that on purpose. They're stepping
on your materials, what they're doing,
they're stepping in your area and
they're doing it on purpose just to,
to so that when you bring it up there
is not the initial recognition of, yeah,
yeah. Like they've already heard
this 20 minutes ago, you know,
they've heard that they've heard
this subject breached 20 minutes ago.
Even briefly. It just takes some of
the wind out of the sails a little bit.
I worked with a guy,
I heard him talking to his friend and
the on the phone and he never saw me do
stand up. He's like, he's in the
green room and he's like, yeah,
this guy's going to have a good
hard time following me this week.
You heard him say that he's bragging.
He walks in and he saw that
I heard. I'm like, Yeah Dude,
I hope you rock it. That'd,
that'd be great. You can't,
you really did your with your,
you know guys and paint like to hunt
men like you're going to do gauge.
It's hilarious. Who was his Garmin and
call them out and then used to fuck Aye.
Aye. Aye. No, do it. I don't remember.
I bring Joey d road whenever I can.
Joey should be a headliner,
but he's just too crazy to go on the
road by himself. Right. Catcher's trust.
Joey who won't show up.
You know why I think back in the day when
you first started doing comedy for Guy
Crushes in front of you for me, because
you'd be insecure, you'd go, oh,
that guy crush,
what am I going to do?
But then you reach an age in a confidence
level. You go, that's awesome. Yeah, I'm,
I'm not gonna ride that same way. Well,
you all capable of be enjoying it.
Unfortunately for some people
guys that go on before him,
it's like a competition, you
know, and they're not enjoying it.
Instead of like watching the, the act and
having fun and being inspired, they're,
they're not enjoying it.
And you could see shows where like if you,
or see you and Joey and,
and anyone else went when every,
when the comics like each other to show
is better because there's a cooler vibe.
I've done shows where it's
Mc hasn't talked to me.
Feature guy was just
being friendly and me.
And then I get on stage almost like
I'm by myself this entire week. Yes,
let's hear it for those guy like,
and there's no connection and there's
no opposed to if your friends are like,
the worst is when you try
to bring a guy in like you,
like you try to pal around with them,
but you realize like deepen this a one
way street. This guy's a Douche bag. Like,
fuck, I'm working with a douchebag.
Yeah. You know, it's always tricky, man.
Going on the road. That was the number
one thing that I hated the most.
So you never knew who
you're gonna work with.
You could be working with some dude with
a real negative energy and I work with
twos that get super drunk and just one
of fallen down and make an ass out of
themselves in the next light. You got to
hang out with them again. You're like,
hey man, you guys want to go to a bar?
No, I don't want to go to a bar with you.
You crazy alcoholic. Fuck
right. And then, you know, no,
no longer have a friend for the week.
Yeah.
I worked with a guy recently who read
news or even worse is the guy who used to
drink and looks down at you
want a shot? No, I don't drink.
I'm trying to look down at
people never looked down. Brian.
Fuck you man. I don't look down at
leave. I'm a little, I don't drink. Yeah,
I've seen drunk John Heffernan.
I've seen sober. Jon had,
I welcome sober Jon Ephrata drunk.
John Heffrons better for all of John.
The phone's breaking up.
I can't hear what I just said.
He's not gonna remember this conversation
anyway. Yeah. There's the guy that John
Hernandez desert drank way better. Yeah.
Way more money way.
Uh,
John was the old John Heffron was easier.
Yeah. What do you mean to get into bed?
And Brian, Brian's got plans.
Um, what was I going to ask you?
You got the one oh,
silly hologram bracelets on.
Do you really think that things helping
you? I know, but I like to wear it though.
I like something like an athlete. Yeah.
It's Kinda cool. It's like a moderate up.
What is the first goes live
strong bracelets. Yeah.
I used to have one for this Q lane that
was supposed to do the same stuff years
and years ago,
but that was really expensive.
This I got free in like
a golf bag or something.
It's supposed to be something
that's supposed to balance
you. It's all nonsense.
Complete total nonsense.
They cannot not be nonsense.
But what the placebo effect
people like take those things.
Then they have all sorts of like benefits.
Their back feels great and all of a
sudden their injuries go away and then if
they deal with the placebo and it works,
then it works.
But it's kind of placebo effect is
some real shit. I don't know why,
but it's some real shit, you know? Yeah.
You just tell yourself and you go, okay,
it's all connected to evade.
The placebo effect is very much like,
like when you're on stage and
you know things are funny.
You know how you got that feeling where
you know things are funny and you just
kind of like trust in it and it just
goes to this sort of magical place for it
just comes out. I think the
placebo effect is the same thing.
It's like you know this
is going to heal you,
you know there's going to
make you better and boom,
it just lights up all
those parts of your brain.
You just have to truly believe in it.
And He'd do it. You're an idiot. Look at,
it's a rubber band,
which should probably bandwidth with
the sticker that would be on underneath
your baseball hat if you bought it for a
little Hologram or your baseball cards.
It shows that it's a real, a upper deck
shit is goddamn ridiculous. Just kind of,
so how long do you think you can keep
this up? This travel on the road?
40 weeks a year cause I that'll kill
them on. What are you running from
running to? What's good? You're
saying sassful you know it's a sign.
It's 80 it's so funny.
I keep joking with people telling people
I'm going to start a mailing lists for
when I'm about 65 in
Branson, Missouri. Oh,
I'm going to do a 1:00 PM show
Yakov Smirnoff specialists,
but it's legit but can be 65 70
at that point. You know who cash.
But I do have a thing I told myself and
I'm putting plans together where I'm
going to retire when I'm 50,
you know,
just done really and only working for
when I want to because I'll still be
relevant. And you know,
there's not really any time,
but that's my goal is I'm in work around
La and work wherever you are, whatever,
who stands up whenever you feel
what happens 10 years from now.
But I'm going to keep running
for the next 10 years.
I wanted to talk to you about this while
we have you on the podcast because now
I'm just remembering,
um,
you were the one that has been doing
these crazy cyber conference shows and
we've actually talked about you on the
show before about you've done these
corporate gigs. Explain, explain exactly
how it goes. Yeah. I brought a tape of it,
but we can't play it.
What it is,
it's with Cisco's telepresence and you
go into a room, just a conference room.
You sit down at a table and then across
from you is maybe three big screen TVs,
maybe about eight inches each.
68 68 inch screen, maybe each
one. Each one. Wow. Okay.
So then on one of the screens was Boston,
the one in the middle was New York. The
other one, Washington DC. In each screen,
imagine 30 40 people sitting in
each screen. So that little squares,
like webcams? No, just a Oh, a group? Yes.
Just like your group,
like an audience.
It looks like a window when
looks like a window. No,
it doesn't look like a Webcam
at all. It looks like. So the,
the screen is filled with an audience.
So if we were to, you have a,
a big sliding glass door.
If we were to set up uh,
chairs and then Brian gets on the
other side of the, of the window,
that's exactly what it looks like.
You're to scale, everything's to scale.
So you're not looking at little guys,
you're,
and then how you sit in the table
because then their table does the same.
It looks like it's one big
round connected table. Dude.
Someone should set up cyber comedy clubs.
Well that's due. So I was
the friend. I wish I had a,
you don't have to show video.
And this is more and more
people are listening to this
on iTunes and [inaudible].
So in your house? No, this, this one
was I, I've done it at a couple hotels.
I just wanted the big chains. The
Hiltons or something has this, this,
this technology and then their hope it
is now you have a business meeting in New
York. You live in Los
Angeles. You're not flying.
You go into their hotel sitting there.
I can look across from you. It's all,
this is a whole chain. Like
all the Hiltons, it's, it's,
I don't know if it's the
Hilton's, I forgot what plan
I was the cliff hotel. Yeah,
but so that's their thing.
So I've done it now
Cisco a bunch of times,
but three or four of them? No.
Are these squeaky clean gigs?
Do you have to be squeaky clean?
Yeah.
In what had happens is in each room is
people who want to buy the technology.
So it's the owners of these companies
that spend 25 million, 50 million.
So imagine those type of guys. Okay,
so you're doing stand up to them.
So then you sit down, are you doing
stand up or are you do my presentation?
No, I do my act. So I sit down and then
you have the Cisco person here going,
you know for a meeting because maybe they
watch a presentation about the system
but Dah, Dah Dah. And then I
get an intro almost like a,
like an mc wood and then
you kind of go off into it.
And how I look at is, you know how
when you do morning radio you show up.
It's just the Dj and maybe a news girl.
It's the same.
You have to tweak your,
your brain.
You know how when you get there
you kind of performance mode,
but you see all the people
sitting there looking at it.
So then you see them and then you could
go in whatever room is the loudest.
That's what you see. So it, it,
it knows if somebody is talking.
So let's say Boston was laughing
really hard, that it, ah,
and the need quiet down and all of a
sudden New York would pop up, you know,
cause somebody talked or, or did something
wrong. I'm looking at one screen. Well,
it would constantly,
well that's annoying.
Why wouldn't it just be the same
screen over and over again? It does,
it picks up whoever's talking.
So then that way the focus
can be on that person talking.
Can't they have it static?
I wouldn't see that from me.
You would want to see the audience
and they would just want to see you.
If you could just have that stat. What if
you fall in love with somebody? Tell me,
Brian, please. Piano music.
Am I done in San Francisco?
Um,
so yeah,
so you do it and then you
would look across from you,
hey guy in the NASA suit.
And then so that's what I would have to
do is you'd have to bring in people, um,
you know, so they feel connected and
then you just do your, your stuff.
Could they do it static where they just
see you all the time and then you, yeah,
because I laid on that piano mother
fucker. This isn't even sad anymore.
It could be a sad if we want it to be.
What do you want to
talk about several way?
Have you ever fallen in love
to talking about sad things?
I think to some of the status things.
Are these people like HD though? Like,
like I mean like really,
really good pitchers.
Like you're looking into a window and the
person's right there, that's the only,
and their faces just kind of come on like
so it was a room you in that you're in
like pitch black.
So you just see like these faces that,
are these bodies come in front of
you eight? No, it's least three.
You have three screens, but each screen
does not have an individual video on it.
They all have, they all have
the same thing. Doesn't weird,
but I'm sure there's adjustments,
but sometimes all three screens will be
one city and then other times it would
split and I don't know,
it's all voice activated so I don't know.
And that would be distracting.
I think if they could keep it static so
that you could just get into your head
and do your material. I think it
can be very much like an audience.
I think that's a real possibility of
cyber comedy club where a comic would
perform in a studio in la or wherever
the hell they are in New York and people
would come, you know like, hey, we're
going to do Austin, Texas and Ohio and,
and you know, you're in the room
with you, like what's up, what's up,
how are you already
doing? And it's like, wow,
where we really are in a room
together like that. Dope. Last,
a couple of weeks ago I did a thing for
Cisco at their place and then I went
downtown to some steak place
right by the staple center too.
This is a great idea for a TV show, man.
So I'll, so doing what you're saying.
I was, now I'm in a steakhouse downtown.
They have a conference room, there's a,
I'm sitting at this table,
almost like the last supper table with
people all on my right and left a screen
and TV in front of me.
I'm looking at another steak
house that was in Tempe, Arizona,
full of a hundred people all sitting
at tables. Just like, uh, you know,
like you're at a restaurant,
they're watching me on TV.
I'm doing my stuff in that 100
people in that room are laughing.
So I would like, and I would
literally do crowd work. I'd go, yeah,
be in the white sweater and the
second table from, what's your name?
And she would shout out Sarah.
He said,
what was the last argument
you got in with your husband?
And then she would have a thing and I
would talk and then that room would laugh.
It's a really, it's kind of crazy. That's
pretty interesting, man. So you can do it.
And people were like, Eh, the
people in the room wanting be, um,
into it yet because, so imagine
watching a comedy central special. What?
Say That again? Like a lot of
people go in. Cisco was wearing,
I had some other trainers that want to
buy the technology. They were saying,
how can you engage or build rapport
with a hundred people that are in a
different city,
not with you.
That was a weird thing that
like is a comic gonna work,
but it works because just like you're
watching comedy central and you're
watching someone special,
you're laughing.
Now imagine if that guy could look
out at you and go, hey, you're a,
you're almost pit and have a conversation
with you so it really adds this whole,
why would they say it wouldn't work?
Look,
as long as you can interact with the
people you can interact with them,
it's going to be a weird thing.
A cyber comedy club was a very,
very interesting idea.
That technology that they have a home
version of that still look at me now,
but you know what I'm saying?
Like you wouldn't have to travel so much.
You know you get,
if you had a cyber comedy club,
you could have people come to
see you all over the country.
They organized the shows,
you know,
and have a be cheap like a movie ticket
instead of like a comedy club tickets
where it's a live show and you gotta to
justify the airfare and all the shit to
get the guy to the club this way is just,
you know,
it's just in a studio somewhere you cut
a lot of the expenses out is cheaper and
the people go and they're, it's a real
show. It's like they're interacting,
you know, and you know, and like,
especially for me when I do question
Anson Shit question and answer shit.
Like you could see that it was really
happening right there. And then,
and I don't know how many cities you can,
let's say you do it at the hotel
where it's set up. If you, if there's,
I don't know what the limit is,
but you could have like yet
10 satellite cities and what,
I don't know what the
technologies were like one,
you had like five cities going at the
same time, but yet one conti audience,
they're just heckling and being douchey.
Just mute them.
I put you on ignore Kansas City.
You just got on the door,
you should probably have a moderator.
You'd have a club owner, which is just,
you know, somebody sitting there meeting
people that are getting out of control.
Yeah, the mute the audience, but the, the
feed still comes through, you know, watch.
It's a Cisco is 8 billion trillion dollar
company and I gave them a legitimate
thing. When you're done with those,
it's a weird thing. You Go, okay,
well we're done. And you know how
when you're done with something,
you're used to shaking a hand or
pat or there's a, okay, we're done.
Well they don't have anything.
And I told them they need a virtual
fist pump where when like, okay,
later I hit a button and a fist just
comes to your screen and then we do a,
you watch this right now,
I'm going to show you,
I will be willing to
willing virtual mansiony,
maybe a virtual handshake,
fistfuls bone dare to business travel,
business fist bump in the world of human
resources, it's not going to exist.
I bet you not going to watch you behavior
with secret handshakes and fist bumps
and shit. There's going to be
a some type of a thing. Whoa.
Maybe like a green light,
a nice green light like a palm.
I invent a two thing like palm,
it shows up in the screen
watching and I'm gonna say this.
Then the ideas can be there. All the
business guys take off their jackets.
You know they have the shirt and ties and
they throw them over the back of their
chairs.
I'm going to invent suit jackets that
aren't real once they just covered the
back of your chair.
So you see that as a piece of your suit,
but you don't have to wear the jacket.
What the fuck is wrong with you?
You got tackled. Brilliant idea. That's
an idea. You're talking about. Signage.
Jackets are never a good idea.
John had fraud.
They're going to go on the
back into herself too long.
Virtual fist pump talking
about your sake jackets bro.
That are going to go on the
back of, because here's the
thing, when you do those,
you don't have to wear dress
pants because they can't it.
They're like newscasters. So the new
look, you can go board shorts, flip flops,
maybe a nice shirt with a tie
fake jacket cover over the thing.
You look like you're wearing
a suit and you got problems.
Brain dog guys are NASA in the
beginning of the show brain doctor,
you need to go see one telling you you're
gonna, you're gonna, we're gonna see it.
You're all gonna for start there John
Heffron I'd be willing to bet you an
insane amount of money.
That fake jackets that you put on the
back of your city will exempt. Okay.
Cause he will exist cause I'll
create them. Okay. You will,
they will exist and they will be a money
pit of disastrous proportions for me.
I need somebody that direct message me.
I need a seamstress.
What is it like dealing with those people
in that world and doing like squeaky
clean comedy only and not being able to
take any chances up there or go into any
weird directions. What does that like
I've always done is that type of comedy.
So it's not weird for them than you do.
You're currently has got me. I'm an adult,
but I'm not, you know, I don't
get ever super grass. I, I'm,
I believe you can turn a,
a clean bit dirty,
just buy things then vice versa.
But yet you are one of the most perverted
people I've ever met in my life. Right.
It's pissed off with that.
Plus I think it's weird when you
have jobs that then affect you.
Like when I used to do morning radio
with Bonaduce, we are on a soccer mom,
a duty station. You have gun buyback.
You guys were on a soccer mom's station.
Yeah. We would like blow. Danny tried to
get in a fight at a matchbox 20 concert.
So that shows you what kind of saying try
match. But in a fight at a mailbox, he,
it was the great, he took off his shirt
and was going to fight the entire row.
Jj at pineapple. Why would the shirt
off? Because better in the bathroom,
I think this is back when
Danny partied, I think, uh,
Danny met up with the listener and
the disappeared, whatever happened.
So he came back in an altered stain. No,
he was never that type of guy liquor.
Um, no. I thought, I think
we was. Um, and he's talking,
he's talking about the story,
so I'm not thinking of, but it was that
date, rape drug, whatever your thing.
He did GHB. Yeah, yeah, yeah. So
yeah, but, but Danny scar tissue,
he did mid to all this stuff. I don't
know how that guy, but so he did.
So then he came out crazy. Did you say
Danny is scar tissue? His whole body is,
or there's no way you can be alive with
all the stuff that he has done. Really?
There's no way you have to be totally
embalmed. What did they do that with frog?
So the body's preserve? Yeah,
formaldehyde. His, that's his entire body.
Really? Oh yeah. He's a Zombie. You can't,
he's not alive. What's wrong with him?
He's just done so much stuff to his body.
What was it like working with that guy?
How long did you work with them?
Different? Kiss him five years.
Five years on the radio. Every morning.
Every 15 in the morning. And Michigan,
which means that's when I scraped off
the ice on my thing. Drove 45 minutes.
How many months a year is it
snowing like that? And Michigan,
it started December and go to
like May. June. Yeah. I mean it's,
so that's a long drive. A June,
seven months. Seven months.
Eight April and yeah, half the April,
half a year. Half it's cold and crappy.
Yeah. Okay. So cold and crappy. You
get up at three 30 in the morning.
You do it stand up at night
still? Yeah, around town. Um,
but it was Austin cause
I would sell out stuff.
I mean there were some benefits I
wasn't playing and I was 25, 26.
Why would you ever want to sleep?
So I would do like radio bar appearances,
you know, like I was that guy movie
premieres, but he got paid a lot of money.
How crazy was daddy? Uh, beyond crazy?
Because the thing with Danny is you never
knew which guy you were going to get.
You can have a guy that you work
with that's a consistent ass,
but at least then you know how to tip toe.
Other times,
Daniel be the coolest human
being you've ever met.
And then you come in the
next day and you'd go,
he's gonna literally slit my throat. The
only advantage, I mean did it. Now we're,
we're really good friends. And at first
he, he hated me. He wanted to hit you.
Um,
well I never did radio before I met him.
I was just a comic round town and I
didn't know how to talk with that person.
It's try having that conversation
with them. It's tough.
So imagine being a 22 year old kid,
not, you know, David [inaudible].
And I was like, yeah, but one time I,
you know, I just didn't have my rhythm.
I just didn't know. So he
hated you because, oh, hated
me. Hated working with you.
Hated just, yeah. Yeah. And he
didn't want to work with you.
He didn't want to know why to me fired.
I just moved back from Los Angeles.
So I moved to from Detroit to Los Angeles
and then got that job and move back to
Detroit and then got fired
maybe three or four weeks later.
And then did he get you fired?
Yeah,
he got me fired and then we
went to Chicago together.
It was an odd for some
weird thing and then we ate.
He didn't suddenly liked me and
then then I was on the shelf.
You know what?
What are you talking about?
We did a radio show together and for some
reason why we were doing it in Chicago,
something clicked where he's like, oh,
I get you and I'll have friend. Okay,
you're in. Then it was
so, I'm so confused. Okay.
You started off together in Michigan,
you did a radio show,
he's got you fired and they got me
fired because they were going to get me,
you know, how did you go to Chicago?
What is this Chicago trip about?
I got fired on a Friday and we were going
to go to Chicago on Monday to do a hit
this loop, the loop in Chicago.
So we do it as a permanent gig.
Well, Danny's thing was a, I can't
believe they did that. You know,
why don't you come to Chicago? We'll
do the show Monday. Puts you up.
I didn't know.
Just took confuses.
He's still doing the show in Michigan
and he does a show car. So yes,
he would do morning shows in
Detroit afternoon in Chicago.
So he would get on a southwest flight.
Wait a minute.
He did a show every day in
two markets. Yes. Oh my God.
We'll get on a southwest flight and fly
from Detroit to Chicago, do the thing,
and then get on another flight. Fly
back. Holy Shit. Yeah. Every day. Yeah.
He did that for a couple months and then,
you know,
then he figured out technology,
but keep,
you know where they can ISD and
at where he would do it in thing.
But he was doing that every day is insane.
Yeah, yeah. Yeah. How long is the flight?
A year? 10 minutes. 20 minutes. 40 yeah.
So it's an on Vegas, like flying to Vegas.
Yeah. And he would do it every day, back
and forth, and then do his radio show.
Holy Shit wrapped in,
you're in Chicago. Yeah.
You gotta give the Guy Credit for that?
No wonder why he was on drugs.
So he got to be on drugs. So I was
fired, but he didn't tell me that it was,
he was like, I can't believe they
did that. I that's like so he didn't,
I didn't tell you that he got fired.
So he goes,
why don't you just come to
Chicago this weekend? We'll,
we'll party that just sucks.
Have friend. But you know, well,
so he's Kinda like probably felt guilty.
I'll let you party in in Chicago with
me and then you're gone for life. Okay.
Did the show with them on that
Monday and he's like, you know what,
I'm going to make a call like we had,
cause he never listened to me.
You know what I mean?
Like what's the problem on the show if
you would just listen to me. He knows.
So anyway, long story short, I came
back and like, Eh, you know what?
We won't fire you but we'll give you,
you got to take a pay cut.
Because I was making, if you
know, keep in mind, I'm 23,
24 morning radio in Detroit,
making $150,000. Wow.
I mean, that's like $1 million to a
23, 24 years. Was this because, well,
why were they given you a pay cut? What
are they doing? You know, because I was,
I had no management or anything and
they're a huge corporation. They're like,
you get the Gig in the first
place. Uh, this huge radio guy,
Dick Perton in Detroit was leaving the
radio station and he suggested to that
management, you need to bring this
Heffron kid in. Keeping in mind,
I'm just at college, you know, so then
they go and you know, dig burrows.
Most standup comedian.
Yeah.
And I was on a show and he was probably
the most famous radio guy in Detroit,
so they hired me just because of that
and put me with Dan. But Dan is the guy.
How crazy. Danny. Yes. Danny. He's the
guy who, and I've told it well, anyway,
he's the one who got me into fighting.
Um, he was really in the boxing and stuff.
So then what he did was he came to the
radio station and he had like headgear
cups, boxing gloves and says, you know,
I'm friends with Jackie Colon, we're going
to go to her place and we're going to,
I want you to learn to box so
I have somebody to spar with.
So he bought me all my appointments.
He bought me all my equipment,
got me crazy coaches and goes, have
friend. I'm going to tell you, I mean,
she got a box so I have somebody to,
and we're going to suffer every day from
12 to 12 to three. That's ridiculous.
So long time to get good at
boxing can just start sparring.
Someone had been doing it forever.
Yeah. So I, so I got to stuff and then,
um,
then me and Danny fought and I would
never been more afraid of my entire life.
Like there's a thing about fighting. You
can be a really good, you go to class,
you're learning,
but you have to have that thing in you
that makes you want to kill people,
which I've never had. I enjoyed
fighting and I learned learning stuff,
but I don't have that. There's that
thing. Dan is a complete psycho.
He completely has that
thing and we'll kill you.
Then that's when that shortly after,
that's when he gave me a concussion.
Hit me right in the back of the head,
um, to people punching on you dude.
Cross guard. That's right. To,
to do cheat. So that's when we,
so he hit me in the back of the head.
I went home,
the girl was dating at the time,
comes to my apartment and goes,
why'd you buy a VCR on my kitchen table
from best buy out a VCR? I'm like,
I didn't buy a VCR. She's like, yeah,
well who's is that ago? I Dunno,
looked saw that the credit card receipt
was my signature. But this was weird.
This was in the 90s when
people bought DVD players.
So I actually went backwards in
technology. Don't remember buying a VCR.
She took me to the hospital and then the
guy did the stand up on one foot thing
and I fell over and he's like,
what's a mat? So then, you know,
I had a really weird duty not to backwards
in a technological progress with,
with a punch.
He knocked you back to the visa and
then after that he recruited me.
We're friends. Why wasn't there anyone
around to stop you from boxing him?
I had no guidance. That's
so sad. I had no guy.
I wish I could've been
your front of and no, no.
I had no guys don't do a chart and
don't get, we need you here on earth.
We need you for your brain.
We need you to be funny.
And we can't have people
after that, Danny, you know,
like me and stuff like that.
Let Him Punch you and fire you
and he's the best guy ever. Yeah.
You just gotta go the big bit of a
gauntlet and then it isn't doing,
so you've got a show in Philly
or something? Yeah, he's married.
He's about to get married again. It
was, he married, uh, I don't know.
How do you know this?
And there's somebody that knows somebody
who knows somebody who's marrying him.
Yeah. Really? Oh, tell me
more. Very interesting. Yeah,
he was dominating. Yeah.
Interesting guy to get in a
fight out of matchbox 20 concert.
You really have in a work because that
crowd is not necessarily violent Oz fest.
Yeah. Of 20. It's guys being forced to
take the girls you've never seen man.
Some emo do's get really pissed when
they see the trick with another dude and
they realize that they're
crying isn't working.
Sometimes they turn like temper
tantrum ish. Right? Yeah.
Well John had fun.
Where are you next buddy?
Tell people where to where they can cut
you up. Towels or what? Well John ron.com.
Right? Two F's W uh, John, uh,
h e f f r o n.com and a Twitter schedule.
And your Twitter is at John Heffron.
Yeah. And John and I met a long time ago.
We was doing the maximum comedy tour.
You,
me and Charlie Murphy and we've been pals
ever since. There was a fun tour. Yeah.
Wise there was a financial disaster
for bud light and all the people put it
together. If they did,
the guy who was a promoter
didn't like no advertising.
We just kind of showed up everywhere.
The kids never did any radio. He didn't
do any, you would expect to sell out, uh,
uh, you know, 7,000 like you okay.
Every show you've ever done
when you go on a city sells out.
Especially for me at that time,
even go four years later I
was selling out like crazy.
But then so you would think and that
just shows you that nobody knew about it.
Nobody knew about.
It was a miss my own friends that know
about it and I didn't promote it very
well on my own shit,
on my website and everything.
I thought they hadn't taken care of.
I didn't think of how to think that.
You're like, finally there's a
tour with a lot of money behind it.
They're going to put posters and they're
going to do some stuff. I didn't get it.
The whole, uh, selling, you
know, the, that promotion is
actually a part of the job.
I never thought of it that way. I always
thought, oh, little take care of itself.
Someone will take care of it.
Right.
You don't take care of it if you
don't let people know about it.
They actually get upset. They're
like, what the fuck, dude?
I didn't even know you had
a show. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I started concentrating more on
my message board and on my number,
my message rather than my mailing list
and Twitter and all that shit after that.
Yeah. You know, it's not when someone
else puts it together, it's not fun.
But it was a fun gig. You know,
we, we had a good time, man.
I would love to do some mortgage like
that with you. We should do some,
some big travel points where you just
have to know our acts are so different.
You know, we should do some, uh, some big
gigs together. You know, where we, uh,
you know, we made it, make our
fans meet how we started. Yeah.
I always thought of a cool
thing where you would, um,
you know how they have all
these four leases places in
every city you go to just,
you can go to any mall or strip mall.
There's buildings.
We just to see the power of the
Internet and go, we're in this city.
We're doing it at the corner of this,
you know,
ran out one of those places for the
day but not a normal comedy place.
Like a restaurant that
went out of business.
Right and you get set up a
sound system and then you go,
we're going to show up and then you
blast it to your network and see how many
people show up in that one area.
That's an interesting idea.
If you knew the venue in advance,
you knew it was a at the pre and
then you'd have to go and just see.
It'd be kind of like a workspace
comedy show, but I don't know.
By the way I should mention this.
What is the shit and we will be doing it
soon is Kevin Smith's Mod castle in La.
It is the Shit I did.
Tom Green's podcasts from there.
He does a live podcast with an audience.
It's fucking fun as shit.
I lost like half standup comedy half
audience like we got to do on there with
Joey. It's, it's incredible.
What did they call it? Pod pod.
Castle Smith Smog cast.
Smith podcast and it's just like almost
like a studio for people do podcasts.
Like,
you know what it's like,
it's like one of those little tiny
theaters where they teach acting classes.
That's what it looks like. It's like
one of those really small theaters.
Seats may be 50 people and they have
a stage and a microphone set up and a,
you just give the dude and SD card. He
slaps it in at the end of it. It's over.
They, they, they sell tickets again in
the ticket's paid for renting the place.
That's 20 bucks, 20 bucks taken in an
old school way. If you think of that,
what's that Guy Camp Wogo
Wobegon that old school radio.
Garrison Keillor. Yeah. Yeah. No, but,
but you're thinking you're doing a live
show in front of live people that's so
old school. The way that they use, uh,
Jimmy Pardot has got a podcast and they
did a live show where they had people in
the audience and it was just
Webcam for 20. It was really,
I did Carolla's podcast.
Tony was,
it was odd because Corola had it
almost like a radio show, you know,
one guy would,
these guys would go out for 15 minutes
and the next guys would go up for 15
minutes. You know, I think
you know, and then you,
you almost felt like I was doing standup.
It was like real when I was doing
stand up on stage with him. You know,
we were just riffing and talking about
shit. It's very strange. I think, um,
the way we do it, it would
be more interesting. Like
the way we do it where it's,
you know, the, the,
the whole podcast is just some long
run on conversation with someone who's
interesting and you do these,
keep having guests come in. Yeah.
New guests and you go to the crowd to
you and you let the crowd ask questions,
give them a microphone. You know, Tom
Green went out to the crowd and then,
you know, the crowd gets to throw
questions at you and talk to Joe,
who are you going to allow any of
that nonsense? None of that silliness.
Yeah. Those are the most people you
got to do that. That would be awesome.
Not The great thing about technology fees.
I was playing UFC a whatever it
is undisputed. Yeah. You know,
from just kind of knowing you
and some other stuff I've done.
I've know a lot of fighters and it's
funny, when I was in a tournament,
every time I would come up against a
fighter that I know I would take a picture
of it and then I would tweet them.
So it's cool that you can
have that much interaction.
Now it could be playing a video game.
Oh there's frank Trigg.
I'm going to let Frank Trigg,
Nolan bought the knock them out
and then you sent him a video. Hey,
here's what's going to happen to you.
Hey,
do you think that you could set it up so
that we could try to do some sort of a
cyber comedy club thing? Do you
mean? If you know these Cisco people,
great to hear is it's be someone who'd
be into doing something like that were
really into,
because the cool thing is is that they
were using me to show that it doesn't
have to be stuffy, but here's another
cool, well they also have the,
I don't know what it's called. It's some
home unit, but not the home unit. Look,
I'm, I'm talking about, but
you could do a home unit,
but I'm talking about setting it up in
a hotel somewhere where you sell tickets
online. The people come to
the hotel. To be honest,
I met so many hotels that I
forgot which one is the one that,
but I'm pretty sure it's like the
Marriotts or some and what you do is you
technically,
how it works for businesses is you rent
out that space and then somebody rents
it out. Whatever. Dude,
we should really sit down all we do shows
over and talk about this because this
could be a great way to do shows
where you don't have to travel.
You can do shirts at Cisco.
I know that like we could go to there
for this last one I did was hilarious.
Right. And when I was in New York, I
wait a minute. Stop. Where Cisco? Um,
off of Santa Monica.
Oh, it's in La. Oh yeah.
The one of the buildings
I've done in front. So they
have like a studio there. Uh,
it's, it's, it's like huge.
Imagine 500 cubicles for people to work,
but nobody works there because
everybody works at home.
It's like their craziest place. You
walk in, they all work at home. Yes.
So it's all these empty desks,
but it's a huge office building.
And then they have a big conference room
with this technology set up in there.
Like,
so they all use this video conferencing
technology that no one goes to work.
Yeah, no, nobody. So when
I went there to secretary,
let me in and I'm a pretty fucking dope.
Yeah.
And I was about to go to do my thing.
Last time I did it,
there were 30 people in the room with me.
Right. So there was some energy there.
Right. This time I show up on myself.
I'm like, oh, there's going to be,
there's nobody, right? One
guy shows up, am your liaison.
So then we walked around the cubicles.
I went to two guys I didn't know
that are working and go, hey dude,
I got to go in there and do stand up.
You need to come in there with
me so I'm not the only one.
You need to sit next to me.
And when I'm doing my material or talking,
smile and laugh the entire like,
I don't even know this guy.
You waited in the waiting room so dull.
So you, you went and grabbed people.
I'd rather two guys and said go need
to know. Not only did you grab them,
you instructed them on how to enjoy our
a diva, John. Yeah. You're a dealer.
God Damn it. Well no, because
now it's about the thing,
cause I didn't want to be there and then
have this guy sitting next to me just
stare at him and he's not getting paid.
You're the one getting paid. Did it?
And it was like a cool kind of
would be hated your comedy. Yes,
well that would suck. But there was a,
two of the coolest guy podcast is like,
we're doing this and for me there's a
1086 people tuned in right now while we're
doing this.
You're doing the same thing.
You're doing standup for a thousand
people right now. Yeah, it's the same.
It was just cool. Let's go. But it
was weird. It reminds me when I was,
uh,
doing a lot of colleges performing,
you'd have to do these noon teasers
where you'd go in at noon and the,
in the student union, what, you
never had to do these, so I,
you'd have to go in. They would make
you go. So you and Brian are studying.
I would have to go up and go, hey guys,
this is, keep my no TV credits though.
Nothing. Stop it. I would go, hey
everybody, I'm John Hepburn on the comic.
He'll be in you. I'll be in the
Rathskeller, uh, tonight at eight. Go.
And you'd have to do,
you'd go around to the tables and this
was part of your contract did to get
people to show up at
the show at nighttime.
Stop that 100% I would do that constantly.
Oh my God,
I've never heard of them.
This was back in the day when I was in
my early twenties I would do 80 to 100
colleges a year.
Oh my God.
This is pre or post any amount of duty.
This is a pre radio. So keep in mind,
I'm 21 concussion to blame. No, no,
2122 so now it's funny.
20 some years later and $8 billion
more for the show that I'm doing.
I'm going around to random people going,
hey guys, I'm going to be in this room.
Can you come in? It's so funny how it
goes in full circle and it's the same,
but you're getting paid way more.
That's hilarious.
I really think that that could be
a unique thing like [inaudible]
those guys are doing would be a
real business, a cyber comedy. Well,
here's what I thought that
Simon and a strip club,
so imagine going into a room gone. I
was turned it. Bell came anyway. So, um,
I'd like to see a girl in Bangkok and
then Bam, you're in Bangkok. Well,
I guess you could do that, but there's
a lot of videos out there, dude.
You are talking to them telling Webcam
show there's Webcam shows and get them
set up so we can do it. Well let's do
it. Let's do a comedy club. I think, um,
if we could set it up with a few hotels
in a few different cities, you know,
and banging out like fight only if it's
online. Yeah. Cause he just need holds.
It's like Nita certain promoter in
each individual town and make sure that
there's seating and then they have
alcohol or whatever they have at the,
at the show. Because you do it at
the hotel. There's a hotel bar.
They can have some or don't come in.
Yeah.
And then they showed his wait staff there
and have it take a cyber comedy club.
We can, this is a great
idea, dude. I've done it.
And have I brought your video to see
him? Oh, well we use the video. Yeah,
you can't. Um, but dude, it's fun.
People are people and it, right.
But you're doing it all
through the corporate network,
whereas you have to be
super squeaky clean.
What I would want to do is use them and
like maybe like get them to have it just
be a, yeah. It's just whatever
you feel like talking about. Yeah.
I don't want to have to
worry about being clean.
I don't wanna have to worry about that.
Well, we can't use your technology. Yeah,
yeah. No, this is,
you're using our technology and they
don't rent it out to whoever wants it.
You could be talking about anything.
We need to talk to them. We'll do it.
Something has come out of this podcast,
ladies and gentlemen, birth an idea.
Make sure you're getting bad fruits.
We do not know. We cannot know,
but that's one of the
beautiful things in life.
Sometimes just you have ideas
and those ideas create something.
Cause the imagination
manifest things in real life.
The imagination seems
like a frivolous thing,
but without it we would have nothing.
It is a real thing. It's a force.
It's a force that makes ideas
appear through the work of man.
I tell you this,
you look around whoever you're
watching this look around your room,
that you're in, everything you're
looking at with somebody idea, mad truth,
everything from everything was.
Thank you everybody for tuning in.
Thank you to the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and you
click on the link for the fleshlight,
you get 15% off when you
enter in the Promo Code Rogan,
Nice beat off to your heart's content.
You silly little monkeys.
Thank you to Brian Red band. Join me
on Twitter clays, join him. He's very,
very sad about his Twitter numbers. What
is your Twitter numbers right now, buddy?
Uh,
I don't know.
We're going to find your mind that mind
go up like four or five hours a week.
What does it, man, 9,409
you have more than me.
Thousand 400 [inaudible] and I did
that thing where I follow everybody who
followed me and then they die.
How bad did that get?
It have to make a lot of lists, so
I, you know what I mean? I had a,
I had to start block.
I had to start a unfollowing people.
I have a few dummies that say
interesting shit cause they're so stupid.
But I was, I was falling
way too many hoes. God.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen.
Um,
thanks for tuning in to thank you
everybody for everything you do out there.
Keeping it real in the real world.
Force positive,
moving it all in a good direction.
Stay strong.
There will be peaks and valleys.
They will be ripples in ways,
but you've got to maintain
your own personal balance.
That's my, that's my word to
collect five mode islands.
That's my, I'm words of the day
ladies and gentlemen, as always,
I love you bitches. See in Vegas, February
4th Mandalay Bay theater. Don't sleep.
Tickets are going fast.
We just killed it with some gay
segue. We, what did you just do?
Tick it off the Buzzer to Cmo.
Whack ass low blood from little Wayne
to NMSDC do needs a roast beef sandwich.
What are you trying to do to me?
We had a great ending to the podcast
jocking the three went to the black sky,
died of aids, knucklehead, Dr Dre stick.
You really think doctors raised a
homosexual for makes you say that
because his Dichter slurred shirt.
While we had a big nights going
out to chose words of wisdom,
ladies and gentlemen, fuck my words
or wisdom. You know what to do.
Shit's hitting the fan.
Stay strong. It's a mad,
mad world out there.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this Thursday's get though the
Christmas podcast with Mad Flavor,
Aka Joe Diaz this Thursday,
probably a two or three depending on what
Joey schedules like Brian Red Band and
who knows who else.
We might have a full couch bitches.
Thanks everybody. Love you. Bye.